i'm ambidextrous
you guys need more practice
have you tried to jack off with the
other hand and just like
it's like a workout no nothing happens
i throw the hand to one hand this is not
the conversation i wanted
definitely leave leave trash taste now
while you can
welcome to this episode of trash taste
i'm the boy
why are you laughing i haven't said
anything funny you sound so robotic
you would i don't know it was like such
low energy and i was just expecting you
to like project your voice and you're
like
welcome yeah like your cadence is really
like uplifting but
just the volume you set it out was just
so unenthusiastic
welcome to trash taste podcast there we
go i'm the monkey brain and today i
in my mirror went ah i'm today with uh
cherry and khan of course how are you
guys doing today
i mean much better now i'm awake after
that scream i needed that scream to wake
me up to get in the zone it works man it
works i don't know if my neighbors
probably wakes them up as well actually
it probably hypes them they don't need
an anomaly
anymore
you got this corner you got this it's
like oh
oh my god so how have you guys been this
week good yeah
pretty good we [ __ ] see each other
all the time
like what you're asking me what am i up
to no i mean because like we
all three of us went on trips this week
oh yeah i want to talk about that
yeah sure we went to rafting it uh was
not
white water rafting it was like playing
a cut scene that's that's basically what
our rafting trip was like
like we had to we had to like paddle
like the maximum was like three times
right right and then the rest was just
floating downstream
it did feel like a shitty uh house at
the dead cutscene right
ask secret is what you press like the
gun once
yeah we had like that quick time event
where you had to press
x three times and then that was like
that was like the interaction with the
cutscene
at one point they were like yeah you can
you can jump in the river and then they
were like yeah so you wanted to
put your foot in me and god just [ __ ]
jumped in head first but then i didn't
realize
it was like this deep so i immediately
was like yes
it's my time and i just like jumped in
and [ __ ] slammed my helmet into the
floor
i'm pretty sure they were going to warn
us that it was too shallow but the
moment they said you can jump in
before they can explain anything else me
and connor just like jumped head first
because it was so hot and we were just
dying to jump in i really
really wanted to jump in the water the
whole time
oh my god but joey went on vacation with
his other friends can you believe joey
is friends outside of us too what the
[ __ ]
the [ __ ] joey they're acquaintances
no um i went up to hokkaido to uh
which i'm so jealous without the boys i
know
what absolute blasphemy yeah but it was
just so [ __ ] nice because uh actually
speaking of which i've got like a bunch
of like presents for the boys oh
okay this is a surprise while joey's
getting his presents out we have a new
camera angle
yeah that's because we need the space
behind it if you hate it
that's tough [ __ ] you're gonna have to
get used to it yeah this podcast studio
is actually relatively small i remember
the first thing chris said
when he came into the podcast was like
wow it looks a lot bigger
but our camera used to be like right in
the back and we basically couldn't use
the center of the room yeah half of it
there's just like a lot of empty space
that we couldn't use if we used the old
camera hey if you'd like to see the
behind the scenes then follow us on
twitter hey
but uh okay oh oh thank you very much
so this is one of the gifts did not get
you a gift this is kind of i've
yeah the first time i got you guys gifts
the [ __ ] snacks expired before you
even ate it
you never told me i should eat them
quickly okay eat these quickly then
we'll just eat these now okay so this is
like a type of uh cookie you know what
yeah you just just rip it over my monkey
brain what am i doing i'm gonna be
civilized
so this is a type of
you're like you're like a five-year-old
yeah
yeah so this is a type of cookie that
you can only get in hokkaido it's kind
of known for it's called shiroi
which means a white white lover he gave
up his job
it was so well wrapped that i just
needed to bust that [ __ ] open
yeah so this is a this is a type of
cookie that you can only get in hokkaido
it's called thank you very much really
really nice like white chocolate uh like
milk cookies cause you know hokkaido is
known for its milk
right hokkaido is known for like a lot
of things dude milk milk
food that's the only way to describe it
everything i had in hokkaido
tasted so much [ __ ] better it's like
cream pie yeah kind of oh don't say that
no it's everywhere oh no it's is it
melted
no no no it's all good it's good
yeah which like when i when i heard you
say like hokkaido has amazing food i'm
thinking
man anywhere in japan already has
amazing food i can't imagine
somewhere leveling up that somehow like
if it's just like the seafood even just
just for the seafood right because where
i was in hakodate it's a
it's a coastal town so they catch all of
the seafood there like fresh
at the [ __ ] port and it's oh my god
they have a fish market there that we
went to in the morning
and all of the seafood that they sell
there they caught that morning so it's
the freshest seafood you can ever get
legit think of the best seafood you had
and just imagine that as just trash
because that's what garbage is garbage
compared to what you can have in
hakodate so i got you another thing as
well because
oh my god okay so there is this uh
there's this you got a wish list on
amazon or something
like repair i wanted i wanted to get
this for you guys because i feel it's
very uh
indicative of the kind of vibe that we
go for all right okay
it's clown juice
give me some clown juices for the boys
yeah so there's this hamburger joint
that's specific only to hakodate not
even hokkaido it's called lucky pierrot
and they have their own branded energy
drinks right because uh do you guys know
what like guarana is
like this the fruit that they use in
like red bull and stuff like that oh
yeah
yeah okay they grow guarana and herd
and so i guess they just took that and
it's literally just
clown juice you literally just sent us
an irl clown emoji yeah i was like
here's your clown card
drink up boys anytime one of us does a
[ __ ] take we've got to take a drink yeah
just take a sip of the clown juice
how is it though uh it tastes like an
energy drink honestly for me it kind of
tastes like
some weird as it's to say it's like a
healthier red bull
it's like a red bull with a stronger
aftertaste yeah i don't know it's
it's definitely got that i think that's
definitely the guarana yeah yeah
yeah i can't decide if it tastes cheap
or expensive
let me tell you this was 150 yen so yeah
i'll tell you
i'll tell you what it actually tastes
like a thai red bull oh really and to
explain
what thai red balls are like so red bull
actually originates from thailand
and and yes i don't know that so redwood
actually originated from thailand but
the version they have in thailand
is not carbonated it's like it's like a
thick syrup
and whenever like the only people who
drink really drink red bull
in thailand it's like truck drivers who
like need to stay up yeah you drink one
and that's like drinking five the
equivalent of likes five red bulls you
get anywhere else
yeah but i think uh i think this has
probably the same amount of caffeine as
like a regular red bull but
i think we're going to be loaded on this
podcast but uh
yeah so but but they also have like the
non-carbonated stuff as well so they
have like guarana juice
which is just this basically it's as you
said it's like a non-carbonated red ball
essentially and it had that it actually
tastes really [ __ ] good
and i think it works better than a
coffee in my opinion even though it has
just as much caffeine as a coffee
so suffice it to say that for the rest
of this episode
we all just [ __ ] had a coffee you're
gonna you're gonna see when when the uh
when when this energy drink hits yeah
because uh we're gonna we're gonna be
like
you'll be able to see the heart
palpitations he's like a beer to like
downer you know
no we're definitely gonna like we're
gonna kill ourselves this episode yeah
but yeah um i just wanted to get you
guys some gifts yeah thank you very much
now i feel super bad that we didn't
get anything no it's okay although we
didn't really get any souvenirs either
for ourselves that's all right but like
hopefully like we'll actually be able to
take like a proper boys trip up yeah
because i know like you guys have been
saying how much you want to go up to the
north right yeah i really do i really
really really want to go in the winter
because it seems like really
a lot of things happening in the winter
oh yeah i want to i want to hit up the
onsen
in the winter that's going to be so nice
yeah just trying to get naked
i just want to get naked we haven't
talked about onsens on this podcast
publicly haven't seen your guys dicks so
much now that i don't even question it
going to the onsen with you it's like
you're mad
the first time we used to like first
time went to the onsen together i was
like oh we got to like
but now it's just like whatever we're
getting naked with the boys another day
with the boys
but like i feel like a lot of people are
afraid to go to onsens for the first
time
because because of that barrier right
where you just have to be naked in front
of the boys i mean
in a lot of countries it's not very
normal is it yeah some people have been
like yeah you want to come to the onsen
with me
and you know they that immediately
they're just like no i don't want to do
that
yeah and they're like oh because i don't
want to get naked and i'm like it's just
that
like it wasn't even like a decision it
was like in the head it was like of
course it's no i'm not getting naked
yeah
yeah but it's like but everyone around
you is naked yeah yeah it's like you're
not going to be the only one that's
naked it's like most european countries
naked yeah right but that's surprising
though isn't it is that like i've
tried to convince so many of my european
friends to go on onsen because
in my head it's just like oh bathing
together is like a very normal thing in
europe in a lot of european countries
right so i'm like oh well if it's
normal in their country and their
culture then it must be easier so
yeah so many times i'm like hey you want
to go to the onsen they're just like no
i think i don't know maybe like
our generation it's like less of a thing
than it was like 20 years ago
yeah yeah in the older generation
because i remember trying to convince my
cousin to go to the onsen when he
visited japan
yeah and it was just it was just like
breaking down layers
right so first i'm not just i'm just
like yeah it's kind of it's kind of like
how can i like because he's the biggest
normal you can imagine right so how do i
explain the
cultural significance of like an onsen
and a hot spring to someone who has
never watched an anime
this is the same cousin that watched the
live action at that one time yes yes yes
and like he's like seven eight years
older than me so he's from like the
older generation as well so
had to be like okay so it's kind of like
a hot tub
but it's like a public hot tub yeah and
he was like oh yeah that that sounds fun
you know so
he was like oh yeah doesn't yeah so it's
so you wear like a bathing suit and
everything right
and i was like okay so here's the thing
here
you just everyone's naked and you know
every
and that's it's just a really relaxing
experience and it's a really
cool experience i mean his voice tone
just like completely changed
just oh yeah oh
oh i'll know about that one chief
because i love how you had to go in such
a roundabout way it wasn't just like a
yeah we get naked it was like
well i mean we have bathing suits we
just take them off yeah
yeah yeah you just take them off you can
wear bathing suits
until you enter yeah yeah because like
what was the first onsen experience for
you guys like because i remember
you guys yeah i think i think it was
when we all went with uh
i think it was us three and allen yeah
yeah in the uh
dance and in uh yeah oh daiba yeah i'm
pretty sure which is like a
massive it's like a super scent or super
insane as it's called but
and i remember the fact of like knowing
that we're going to get naked in front
of each other
that was just like i i think i just
built it up my mind so much because i'm
just like
oh it's it's about to happen i mean it's
about to happen i mean i remember that
day like we all
stepped into the onsen yeah and alan was
like all right lads whip him out
let's just get it out of the way let's
just like let's just
get on the table get the messages out
let's gather around in a circle
and we'll just look at our each other's
dicks and then just be over
it and we're like all right three two
one we'll look at this is like okay
we're good
no one's popping a fat all right we're
good
yeah and then it just literally took
five minutes and then i was like
completely comfortable
and then it was an amazing experience
and i feel like people who are
so afraid to go over that barrier are
missing such a good
experience it's an experience you can't
really get anywhere else i feel like
even i've been to kind of you know
public uh you know bathing places in
europe as well but this just
yeah i don't know it's just i don't want
to say it it's different but
you know it's there's something that's
not quite right there's the vibe
it's just different yeah yeah it's
definitely like vibe check
hey yo onsen check constant check yeah
bruh
i don't think we have public bathing
places in europe do we but we have like
the saunas which
uh it's kind of similar right i guess
yeah you don't really
bathe together you just get in the sort
of naked and some people are like you
know they'll cover themselves
i don't know because for me it's not
just the onsen experience it's like
everything around the entire experience
like getting out of the onsen when
you're like especially in the winter
sitting out in the in the public onsen
when it's like really cold or sometimes
raining
and i've heard when it's snowing it's
amazing as well yeah
like that's like i've heard it's like
proper anime whether like there's mist
and everything yeah yeah
i want to experience that one day but
after coming out and having that
drink of cold milk yeah that's like the
most refreshing
hand on the hip hand hands on the hip so
what do you do you have to like put your
hand on your hip
drink the milk in one and it's like the
most refreshing glass of milk
but it's like vibe right you gotta do it
and then having like an izakaya beer
afterwards is just
[ __ ] incredible yeah i just it makes
when you're in an onsen for some reason
it makes you want to just
be a ceo and talk business like i don't
even have business to talk about but
i'll be like
gentlemen let's discuss the topic at
hand and then like
animated it just makes you want to talk
about important things
with three other people so it's exactly
the same kind of vibe but like
a different kind of vibe but like we so
we went to the the other day went to a
cigar bar
no i don't know what it is about having
a fat cigar in your hand
you just you just you just want to talk
business and you're like you take up you
take a puff you're like
we have a problem we need to eliminate
someone
there's a rat in the group we got
exterminated
i remember we went for uh cigars with
pewdiepie right
yeah yeah yeah and uh he was like damn
your voice got even deeper with
signal i was like i was made for this
feeling
i was like oh my god i could finally
understand why mafia bosses
feel so powerful with a cigar in their
hand because it's like it's got an
energy to it yeah yeah
yeah i don't i never smoke like at all
but for some reason yeah the idea of
cigar i was like that sounds good i like
that well because unlike a cigarette
right like you don't inhale the cigar
smoke right yeah so i mean
like don't get me wrong it's still bad
for you it's still terrible it's still
terrible for you and you come out of the
bar smelling like you've just like
puffed an exhaust pipe
yeah you know what i mean that's that's
kind of the smell the smell that yeah
but man you feel so powerful like just
with that aura of cigar
around you like yes i just came out of
the cigar
i do business yeah you do have like a
different aura around you don't you
yeah yeah just feel powerful yeah it's
it's like when you order a drink at a
bar
it's like you're like the virgin when
you order a drink at the cigar bar it's
like oh there's a chat he's like what do
you want name a cocktail any cocktail
a vodka what do you always get again
espresso martini
yeah espresso martini if you haven't had
it it's an amazing drink
uh it's just coffee just with a vodka
base yeah pretty much
it's amazing it tastes just it's just
coffee with attitude really i love my i
love my food
am i not wrong what a terrible way to
decide it's a coffee with attitude
that's like it is describing anything
why are you
i'm right because it's such a like i
don't know that sounds like a
how a disney character that you
introduced in a in a short
oh yeah he's the bully with attitude
like
i'll take a coffee with attitude please
hold the attitude
i hate it here i hate it here
it's like today when you got a
frappuccino and you're like
no i didn't just get a frappuccino i got
an espresso fresh you know
it's like oh my god you couldn't enough
sandwich any more white it's like 35
celsius i want to i want an ice cream
and a drink in one
but i also want a coffee so yeah i don't
i normally think
uh frappuccinos are awful but i you know
i bent my own morals yeah so you
basically got a frappuccino with
attitude right
okay i hate it here i hated you so much
just add anything with attitude it'll
just make it sound bad all
the [ __ ] comments now are gonna be
like damn that was something with
attitude yeah
i want that i want that to be a meme oh
no that's going to be a meme now
i'm going to describe everything with
something yeah it's something with
attitude now
you're welcome speaking of cigar bars
yeah i think
the topic for today that we wanted to
discuss was uh night life in tokyo right
yes
or in japan japan in general true true i
mean i wouldn't
know i haven't been at night outside of
japan
for a while
because i mean like what is a typical
like nightlife for like say
uk or thailand or australia um because
like i don't know what the nightlife is
in thailand
at all i mean the nightlife in thailand
is
i mean oh let me ask a question does it
exist yeah of course
that's all thailand is that that it
definitely it definitely exists and
there's different
there's different kind of vibes you can
go for you can go for like a disgusting
cheap
like not um nightlife in bangkok or you
can go for like some more extravagant
bars and everything
it's it's very varied but i don't know
if that i would say that there's like a
cot like a significant
significant culture that pertains like
all of
all of thailand but i feel like with
japan there's definitely like the
izakaya culture yeah which i [ __ ]
love
like you talk about nightlife in
thailand whenever i'm in thailand
i just go to a izakaya because i like
the vibe that much yeah yeah
that's the thing right like i feel and
izakaya is just
i mean should we explain what an izakaya
is just in case people don't know sure
for those who are uncultured
um basically a japanese pub
basically but like it's like it's like
it's like a restaurant and a pub
75 percent pub and 25 restaurants
yeah let's say yeah but like in a pub in
the uk but it's not depressing yeah yeah
it's depressing and also
for some reason i always feel pressure
to leave in the uk
yeah or like just drink like not sit
down and eat oh yeah i have this
pressure that's like
drink don't you're not here to eat right
because like when you go with your your
friends to the pub
i'm always that [ __ ] he's like i'm
getting a meal
yeah because it's just it's just really
inconvenient because you're there with
like a table full of pints
yeah yeah and then there's this guy who
just orders like a three-course meal and
you're like where are we meant to fit
this
i don't give a [ __ ] i got to hold that i
would like slowly nudge the 12
beers out of the way to make room for my
like extravagant curry from weather
spoons
and the tables like down here you're
like this
is like bombing out do you do you like
pubs in the uk
yeah i love them in london i thought
london had great pubs i don't know i
really don't like pubs pubs
pubs are the one thing about the uk that
i like anytime i go out the uk i'm like
yes this is a much better drinking
establishment than a pub
because it's just i don't know what it
is about pubs in the uk i just find it
so [ __ ] depressing
because yeah it depends it depends which
one do you go to london has
a ton of like pubs that are like really
lively and
really great atmosphere but they're also
equally as i mean you guys took me to
one
uh it was like a gaming pub right that's
shut down
oh really yeah that pub was a mess there
yeah i wouldn't i wouldn't even call it
i wouldn't even call it
that was like a gaming bar but like the
dirtiest gaming box
yeah what was it called again meltdown
meltdown it was like
a gaming bar with like five pcs one
dirty old wii u no it wasn't even a wii
u
are we you and like they would be like
the same people who would hog the pcs
and there was no limit or anything so
yeah
it was just awful it was terrible yeah
you know you compare a gaming bar
anywhere else and you're like that dude
they've got
games yeah they got real like the way i
would describe meltdown is it's it's
basically like a unibar
but it was but they charged more than
the unibar it was just this it was like
a run down bar
and like every single bar in london that
is even remotely interesting i feel is
sort of run down
unfortunately yeah i can see that
because i don't know the thing about
pubs that
i i hate is that for some reason they
just seem so dark i don't know it's it's
everything they're like i think what
pops are you going to man there's so
many in london that are so
anytime i go to like a pub styled bar
like
anywhere else the first thing i notice
is man it's so bright in here
this is nothing like british pubs this
is nothing like british pubs at all are
you like going to the pubs that are like
down the alley
it's like like the proper like local
pubs because in the uk
there's the pubs that anyone goes to and
then there's the pubs that have like the
exact same 30 people going right now
yeah
and those are the depressing as [ __ ]
yeah i don't know most 90
of weather spoons i'd say fit under that
category yeah okay most weather spoons
are weather springs is a brand of pubs
in the uk it's just like this ultra
treat
brand and you took me to one i did take
you to one i think
the reason people go there is because of
the very very cheap drinks and cheap
food that you use what was it like five
pounds for like a full course meal or
something
right you basically get like a full
course meal with an alcoholic drink for
like
seven pounds which is like nine dollars
um
in london in london which is like in
london the drinks alone normally were
like eight dollars which i'm probably
people in california are like oh that's
sure
like in the uk that's bear in mind where
i grew up yeah
a drink that's over three pounds which
is like four dollars like whoa yeah
yeah because of this guy yeah like if
you go to a pub in australia like for a
pint it's like nine bucks
yeah i mean where i the what the weather
spoons this is the cheap areas
where i i grew up it was like their main
selling point was like two pound pints
and sometimes some of the special brews
were like one pound sixty
wow so that's like two dollars something
for a pint yeah
and you have no no wonder that there's
like people are there from like 2 p.m
until 9 p.m just like dead getting their
money's worth
yeah because like to me pubs are just
the place where you pre-drink before you
actually go out to the establishment you
want to go to right that's that's that's
how i see it whereas
with uh izakayas i can [ __ ] stay
there from the
beginning of the night at the end of the
night yeah you don't feel pressured to
leave and you normally have like
they're normally just cordoned off
decently well when you feel like
it's just you and your mates yeah yeah
whereas sometimes the pubs having to see
everyone around you is a little like oh
my god it's busy
that's the one thing i don't like about
i guess like uk style pubs and there are
a few
of those in japan as well um there's
this place called the hub
which i'm sure you boys are aware of is
uh don't go to there by the way because
it's like it's like going into a uk pub
but in japan so why the [ __ ] writer
okay but it's a little bit brighter i've
heard though if you're a foreigner and
you really want to pick up
some people who are really into
foreigners oh yeah yeah yeah they're
probably there because they know that
foreigners go there
if you have the yellow fever but can't
be bothered to go the traditional route
go to the hub yeah yeah but shibuya
you'll be fine
yeah but like like every time i go into
a hub
it's just well first of all it's like 99
foreigners it's also very depressing
it's also very depressing because it's
it's
it's like kind of structured like what
i'm saying right
it's structured like a uk pub where like
the seats are kind of sporadic and then
everyone is standing around you so you
just feel really claustrophobic yeah i
don't mind standing and drinking
sometimes standing is fun
i don't know like i i need a table yeah
there definitely needs
needs to be a table there where i can
leave my drink if i'm just like standing
in the corner which
sometimes on like a friday or saturday
night in england where some
pubs are crowded and you just have to
stand there in the middle of the floor
just with your mates i'm just like
this is this is not the vibe i want to
go my legs hurt i want to sit down
like the thing i like about izakaya is
that you're always sitting down you have
your own
sanctioned corner where you can just sit
and talk to your mates and it's just
like
the perfect kind of catch-up vibe that i
look for when i just want to
just chill with my mates and just she's
just so cheap like you can go to any
izakaya here and like the most you'll
pay for a beer is like what like 400 yen
maybe that's like a pretty that's that's
an expensive one yeah i'm saying like
the max
normally you pay between 200 and 300 yen
for like
a beer which is like two three dollars i
went to an izakaya though whereas 50 yen
beers
what's the point 50 pm how do we even
compete because one thing that doesn't
make sense to me right
is that sometimes it's cheaper to drink
in an izakaya than it is to go to a
family martial
kombini and buy like a can of beer buy a
can of beer
which like can you imagine if that was
the case in the uk like if going to
tesco's it's more expensive than going
to your local weather spoons
i'm just like nobody would drink at home
yeah everyone would just be out
constantly drinking
i think the uk economy would just stop i
think i think it would
the country would fail oh my god yeah
but like the i think the one thing i
like about izakayas is that
again like even people who don't drink
can still go to an izakaya and have a
good time
because as as you know we've established
like it's mostly like
drink based but the food a lot of the
times is also so freaking good and cheap
that you could probably you probably
won't have as much fun yeah if you
weren't drinking but
you could easily take your friend who
doesn't drink at all and they'll
probably still have a
you know a decent time right yeah
because like the food there you can
easily order
a lot of like snack kind of foods it's
like it's not like you have to order a
meal
yeah you know what i mean it's all your
giant [ __ ] pub burger yeah yeah
exactly
i will say that i do feel like the food
is a coin flip sometimes at the izakayas
you can normally tell which one's gonna
have bad food but
sometimes the food is just really bad
are you only saying that because you got
no idea i did get food poisoning
i did get food poisoning very recently
but then the more i've been living in
japan and the more i've been eating out
at restaurants in japan the more i
realized like my god this food is so
much better than the izakaya food yeah
yeah it's fine yeah yeah you know
normally just sticking to karage and
which is like the japanese boneless
fried chicken yeah yeah i mean yeah
don't get me wrong like the izakaya food
is good but there's definitely like if
you want problems
there's something like a proper
establishment there's sometimes there
are many
kind i'm eating it and i'm like god this
food is depressing it's like
really like there's one near our where
we're filming this that like the
you know the one it was the underground
place yeah yeah yeah
and they had like the driest chicken i'd
ever seen in my life you'd think of like
they'd like left this chicken out to
like die in the sahara desert before
they like
harvested it yeah it was pretty anemic
yeah yeah everything on it was just kind
of like
all right i guess you just didn't love
your job today yeah the food
yeah that that one is definitely like
it's it's not horrible
you know it's gonna be that that bad
when like the menu everything is like
150 yen oh yeah well you get what you
pay for something
right right right but like comparing
izakaya food to some of the like
the pub food that i'm used to i don't
know
i think pop food's really [ __ ] good
in the uk am i really yeah maybe i'm too
white to make this point
i don't know because if i had a choice
pub food is where i
go if i like have no other choice or
whatever i can't be bothered to i
promise right hand on heart if i had to
choose between izakaya food and english
pub food i'd go with pub food
no joke no joke i've had food
joey's [ __ ] biased no i'm not not
he's never gonna admit that no no
i don't care about your opinion okay
shut up for a second
okay fine okay like because it's the
kind of the same thing with australian
pop food as well
i don't know man i can't comment you ask
these are wild cause australian because
australian pubs
uh is kind of the same as the uk pubs
right where most people just go
to drink usually it's very [ __ ]
depressing because it's just a bunch of
like middle-aged dudes have been sitting
there since like 2 p.m
right just like wasting their life away
but like a lot of pubs
in australia they have really [ __ ]
good food but the problem is is that you
only get a set portion of food
for like a stupid amount of money right
right and so sometimes
it's like a cost thing yeah well yes so
what i'm hearing is that i smell
bro joey's broke yeah you will be
once you go to an australian pub you
will be it's like 25 bucks for a [ __ ]
pizza it's like it's just not worth it
but like
but the thing is is that with australian
pub food a lot of it's good but it's
just like
you know even before you go into the pub
what food is going to be there
yeah yeah this is so little variety you
know same thing could be said with
izakayas
but i feel that it's always the same
[ __ ] in izakayas i don't know man like
different izakayas have different things
that they specialize yeah but then i
feel like yeah
and like pubs
the reason i love izakaya food is like
they're like designed to go
well with the beer or alcohol that
you're drinking it just it's just like
the perfect
it's like the synergy you were talking
about the pizza synergy i was right
about that by the way
it's it just synergizes so well together
whereas with pub food
it's it is like the same it's just like
you put this in your stomach
i think yeah sometimes it is but not all
the time like there's been plenty of use
guys we've been to where i'm like this
is just
weak like this is mid as you would say
joey
i mean i wasn't but even like even like
the mid izakayas are still better than
like
some of the best pub food i don't i
don't know i i just don't like pubs i'm
sorry england i don't like pubs you know
what though i do
really like irish pubs for their food
because i feel that at least with irish
pubs unlike uk pubs there's a little
more variety in the food and there's i
feel
at least from my experience i feel like
i took you to shitty pubs though yeah
but i feel less pressure to get out of
an irish pub than i do at uk pub if i'm
not
just sitting there drinking well i like
irish
dublin or yeah dublin and i went to
something like limerick and stuff like
that
all around ireland yeah i mean the norm
in the uk uh apart from england because
i think a lot of england is just
depressing outside of the big cities
no offense um like in the small towns in
like whales and stuff there's some
really fun pubs because it's just like
20 yeah but i'm not going to go to wales
there's no reason to go to wales jerry
i'm sorry
i'm sorry i'm sorry wales it's true we
have to accept that fact unless you like
i like ship do you like nature joey i
like sheep all right do you like
rundown castles do you like those um
this is hit or miss for me
all right well you're lovely
all it is well there's not really too
much time i want to go to that [ __ ]
lake that has the longest name in the
world
oh no that's not like that's a town oh
it's a town yeah and it's uh
is the town name
i actually was going to make a video
where i went to that place i actually
filmed it
was that was that the town where the
news anchor pronounced perfectly
and that just went viral just up the
road from planned by to push
the temperature got to 21 celsius so
like 6 million views
yeah yeah so i i went i went there and i
filmed a video actually yeah like i have
all this footage still and like
so wait so what's in it it's just me
going around this place oh she's
checking out but i mean like what's the
town like
it's [ __ ] dead it's [ __ ] nice this
is dead because no one can pronounce the
place
maybe i don't so it's about it was like
two hours drive from where i grew up
so i asked one of my mates i was like
hey can we go here and just film a bunch
of [ __ ] i don't know why i was like [ __ ]
it
maybe something fun will happen nothing
fun happened obviously
but there was also a climbing place that
we wanted to go to so like we'll just go
there after we're done
you mean a hill no no like a climbing
gym right oh
huge warehouse pretty cool so if you
want to go there there's a climbing game
but i went there and it was just a bunch
of tourists from england
all right who were like old very very
old like 60s
just hanging around just checking it out
there's like a gift shop tiny
and then there's a bunch of stores and i
went in there you know asking like
because we were in a really uh west part
of wales and they normally could speak
welsh i was like oh well
maybe i'll ask around see if anyone can
speak well yeah no one can speak [ __ ]
welsh
really yeah i was surprised because
normally in that far west i think that
county is the one with the highest rate
of welsh literacy right
right so yeah nothing there nothing
there so if you've ever wondered what's
there
uh nothing no that's just a really
comically large train sign
yeah it's actually how do they fit in is
it like on like size two fonts
you know like the normal uh so normally
in the uk each one has like a the
standard size of uh font yeah it's quite
big
they literally just add it on there's a
really yeah there's a really funny thing
yeah there was a really funny image of a
guy like standing next to it and it's
just
like 10 meters it's really really i i'll
have some footage up from
the video that mudan can just show on
screen right now it's [ __ ] huge and
yeah it's sad because none of the trains
stopped there either
there's there's a really like train that
goes direct to london that doesn't stop
through there and i think it's only
local trains and
i mean at least you have plenty of time
to read it as you go past i want to hear
how like the train lady pronounces it
like is there like an automated message
that that
so it's shortened to like pg or sh
which is still yeah awfully long it just
sounds like you had a lot of flame stuck
that's right
right right but okay the problem is
right even with whales right if you look
around the rest of the map
like all the town names are just as bad
really around that area to pronounce i
can't pronounce some of them without
taking like three minutes to look at it
and be like
it's kind of hard there's a nice tangent
yeah yeah cute little town of wales
don't go there nothing
don't i mean i live next to some like
weird weird sounding places as well i
remember when joey came to visit i took
him and aki to uh this place called
devil's dice devil's dyke
i remember saying that oh yeah i'm going
to take you guys to devil's dike aki's
face was just like
jordan what did you just say
because do you guys like is dyke does
the word diet have the same meaning yes
yeah but it also means like a hill right
but there's tons of [ __ ] up names in
the uk there's like there's places
called like white knight
and stuff like that yeah there's another
place i live next to or close to called
cuckfield
yeah yeah every time i try
every time i'm on the train and it goes
past that i just have a little laughter
myself
there's like [ __ ] fosters
fosters finally so it's like this is the
train to [ __ ]
i feel like a five-year-old every time i
go on going on that line i can't
remember what line it is it's a
piccadilly
piccadilly line like the dark blue line
every time i and
because i haven't lived in london for
like like a few years every time i go on
there
and i hear it i just i just have to
laugh bust a little smurf you're like i
completely forgot to be thinking
there's so many that are just like swear
words i don't know how this
is like a thing how did we get this
how did this happen we just like in
australia we just we don't have anything
like that it's kind of sad we just have
a lot of lives you're new
yeah honestly and like a lot of the
names are just named after like uh
indigenous
names so they sound funny but they're
not like [ __ ] feet
i i i was lying about talking to you
about this i was like why is there a new
south wales like south wales was never
good to begin with
why are we making another one i don't
know maybe start up from the ground up
make it a good one
honestly i don't know like the only like
funny named place in australia that i
know is uh
banana oh it's just a is this a town in
queensland called banana and it has this
thing called the big banana which is the
guinness world record for the largest
banana statue in the world
why did they just name a town after that
one scenario
oh no it's because also like every
banana in australia grows in banana
questions that probably makes more sense
you should have led with that before you
told us that anyways
i have no idea why it's called banana
but they screw a lot of bananas yeah
it's
the only place they grow bananas oh okay
well that makes a lot of like now that
you've explained the context that
there's a lot more stuff yeah exactly
so we just have stuff like that but like
i wish i [ __ ] lived in a place called
cockfield
that'd be hilarious that'd be the best
that would be the best [ __ ] like
conversation feel like it would grow
tired yeah yeah but it's like where are
you from cockfield and you immediately
get a laugh it's like
i have already blended in with the
conversation how did you just gotta tell
them in japan when they're like sunday
moscow and he was like no
is like my number one kind of drinking
establishment that i enjoy throughout
the world
i mean anyways the easiest it's the
chillest it's the chillest
it's always nice all foreigners love it
because it's so easy you press the
little button
sometimes it's all you control yeah
because you don't have to order at the
bar you never have to order them never
never i will say that is a hundred times
better than the uk
you order all your food and drinks from
a tablet there's no pressure to get
water at the bar and they just bring it
to you
there is uh one of my favorite izakayas
i go to a lot with my uh
other friends is uh it's one in
ikebukuro uh i don't know what it's
called anymore it used to be called
kobayashi's i think i took you guys
there
i remember basically it's it's like it's
uh on the west side
of ikebukuro and it's underground and
like it's like it's exactly like in
izakaya
so it has like food and everything but
you pour your own drinks
oh yeah i think i've been to that one as
well and there's like a huge like tub
like it's like a [ __ ] barrel full of
miso shooter
like miso soup and it's just all you can
drink miso soup as well it's the best
[ __ ] thing ever because it's just
like because miso soup is like
the ultimate hangover drink in my
opinion yeah because
like another thing i want to talk about
when it comes to japanese drinking
culture
is nomihoudai oh which is um all you can
drink
which any time you anytime someone from
england
or like america or someone comes here
and they
see how many like they they learn about
the all-you-can-drink culture yeah yeah
yeah it's like
boys i'm i'm moving here i'm coming out
every night
every australian i've taken to a normal
holiday has always either been like
so is there like a drink limit or
they're like
oh it's only for like 10 minutes all
right like it's like happy hour right
it's like no you can do it for as long
as you want they're just like
how are they how much is like a typical
nomihoudai
1500 for 30 minutes is it no no no no
it's cheaper than that you go either
either it's like i've seen like 2 000
yen for two hours yeah
i think it's it's about so it's about 20
bucks for two hours of all your
computers where you go but generally
it's around that price around that price
and compared to like everywhere you see
in england
and everything that's like a massively
good deal
exactly it's like why would you not like
even if you can't drink that much right
yeah yeah
why would you not take that even if
you'd like
i'm at like a brisk pace yeah it's still
a good value for money yeah because even
like
say like you know it's like 500 yen for
a beer yeah
even if you drink four beers in the two
hours you're still getting your money's
worth yeah
yeah so it's like every time i'm just
like i don't really feel like drinking
that much
let's go let me hold it i i remember
because obviously when you move here you
kind of like stop wanting all you can
drink because you're like it wears off
yeah yeah well the first few times i
visited here i remember thinking like
treating it like an olympic event i'm
like right how many can i do in the chat
no because because that's that's what it
would be like if there wasn't all you
can drink in england
right well it would be yeah that's how
we think because that's how we're wired
you're like yeah you're like 80
speed running i was like i was like
get the clock ready time time
i remember i literally had this dilemma
i was like i was drinking a beer and the
first one i smashed it back no problem
yeah yeah
it was easy second beer i was like [ __ ]
i'm two seconds off pace
like i remember i i actually remember
being like i'm one minute off the pace
actually i'm so good
i was like exactly the same you're like
if how many
how many beers do i need to drink to
make this worth in how many can i go
over yeah you're like calculating this
in your hair to be like okay if i drink
one beer every five to ten minutes then
i can smash this many beers and i would
be like
earning back this amount of money you
know what i mean yeah yeah
they're trying to get like stalks
because because we
i remember this we i first came here as
a tourist we visited a bar that had 200
yen
beers yeah i thought okay that's my new
baseline yeah for all you can drink
i need to make sure i get more of my
money
i need to make sure it's more better
value than 200 yen a beer
so i think we went to one that was like
2 000 yen for two hours and i was like
okay in my head i'm working it out i'm
like okay yeah that's ten beers and then
i need to get at least ten beers yeah so
i was like all right i gotta get 11.
just to just to get an under so i feel
like this was worth coming to
and i remember i was in so much [ __ ]
pain on like the ninth beer
yeah that i got because we were eating
as well yeah my stomach was like
because i think it was like eight beers
in where i was like i don't know if i
forgot to tell you but you can get other
drinks too like it's not it doesn't have
to be just
i knew that getting all you can drink
like spirits was playing with fire oh
yeah and i would i would have been like
on the floor
so i'm like nah i'll stick with beer
because beer is like the natural piece
now i'm gonna take you guys to the 50
yen beer place because it's not an oil
you can drink but it's 50
i mean it's 50 yen so it might as well
be all you can yeah right because i feel
like that's just the difference in
mindset between anyone from like the
west
people in japan right because when
anyone in the west comes over and hears
all you can drink or you can eat it's
it's a it's the same mindset where it's
just like
i've got i've got to [ __ ] speed run
this optimize this what is the optimal
speed one strats
all you can drink and japanese people
are just like you know we just drink
however much we feel like it's just like
the pressure of not having to know how
much i'm gonna
yeah because i think it works on like
the trust system yeah because i remember
we trust you not to be a [ __ ]
alcoholic because
that's why this would never work in any
other country but like japan
yeah because i remember i went to like
uh i went to this uh kind of like no it
wasn't a wine bar was like the place
that they make wine what's that called
winery that's that's the place so i went
to this winery with sydney um just
outside of tokyo
um and they basically had a cellar of
about like a thousand different wines
right and basically you could you could
sample as much as you
as much as you like for ten bucks ten
bucks you had a seller of a thousand
that's like
that's gonna be some willy wonka test
it's like if you actually go greedy
you're gonna like get killed
that's exactly the point that's exactly
the point i'm trying to make so uh
so me and sydney went in being like the
exact same mindset where it's like there
must be a catch there must be a gadget
one of them is poison so we go down
there and there and they give us like
this little cup right it's like the
super small cup
uh where you can pour like i'd say a
third of a glass of wine into it okay
and these japanese people were just
pouring like
one little drop like two little drops
now just like just like letting it
letting the drop like sit on their
tongue yeah yeah and then we were just
like
but we can draw we can pour however much
we want rice sorry in sydney
like because that's that's the thing
it's based on the trust system yeah yeah
but
you know if you want to but but if you
want to you can just pour however much
you want for as many wines as you want
and no one's going to stop you right so
there's something there's something
similar to that that i saw in uh
oh [ __ ] where was it i think it was in
nagano when i went for a trip it was
like a sponsored trip and
at the station because nagano is kind of
known for its sake
yeah there was exactly the same thing it
was like 50
to like 100 like barrels of all sorts of
different sake and it's like yeah again
like it was like one of everything yeah
it was like yeah it was like a thousand
yen for like all you can test
oh you can test oh you can it's not all
you can drink it's all you can test yeah
yeah
all you can sample and i'm just like
hell yeah
but but there's nothing stopping you
from sampling as much as you're like
right
i was like 20 and i was like i'm only a
fifth of the way through this i'm about
to [ __ ] like imagine if you can ask
for a free sample but there's no one
stopping you from asking for unlimited
free stuff
you get unlimited free samples that's
basically the mindset
so it's so like we're here as a
westerner thinking we got the [ __ ]
cheat code to this
yeah so we can just like it's like
bottomless fries but if you can go up
and get your own fries right
it's like it's like having a buff in
this country it's like being british
with
the alcohol it's like oh [ __ ] yeah
what's like another
establishment that's like very specific
to like japanese nightlife because i
like to think that like the
karaoke nightlife i mean karaoke
nightlife here has just got it
done like it's it's it's the perfect
it's the perfect kind of place for
karaoke because
i didn't realize until recently but like
the karaoke in japan
is so much different to the perception
of karaoke in western countries because
i remember
when uh yumi and felix
when we took felix to a karaoke for the
first time he didn't want to go
yeah he was kind of like oh karaoke
cringe that sounds cringe because i
think in his mind
his idea of karaoke is an open bar
karaoke yeah
which i think a lot of people think i
think a lot of people think because in
japan i feel like
after the izakaya you know or after
going to a pub in england
the the president is after the pub you
basically go clubbing there's no other
place to go but in
in japan you'll go home and watch yeah
yeah exactly right
but in japan you can just go to karaoke
and just continue the sesh there
also hang out with your mates and sing a
bunch of songs as well it's all you can
drink it
again it's all you can drink everywhere
you go in japan you can get all you can
drink
it's [ __ ] great it's all you can
drink and the karaoke establishment is
open 24 hours yeah
which is just like a power move yeah
although i swear like whichever brand is
offering because not all of them do all
you can drink and some of them do it for
like way more expensive than others oh
yeah i never know which
[ __ ] one it is so i just walk in and
i'm like please be the cheaper that's
like yeah that's the thing though like
you have to kind of
go around to each brand of karaoke chain
yeah yeah and kind of be like
okay this is the cheapest one for all
you can drink this is the most expensive
one for you can drink so you have to
kind of be like okay do i
take value over price or price over
value yeah
right because you know that if you go to
the cheap ones the food is probably
going to be like not that great
because like i've never like my entire
life i've never really enjoyed karaoke
until i experienced karaoke in japan
right because
it's not only it's not only like having
having a private room so to explain
japanese karaoke you have this private
room
where you can just sing as many songs as
you like that you choose
um there's no one watching you apart
from your own mates and you can just
have fun and sing whatever the hell you
want it's basically just karaoke at home
right they also have like every single
like western song so yeah yeah
so like they have a selection that is
like it that eclipses everywhere else
i've been to
they have like english songs chinese
songs korean songs and obviously
japanese
anime songs i was about to say
man singing singing anime songs while
you're playing it as a weeb
that was like i remember my first
experience was with joey and it was like
one of the funnest experiences
ever it's like seeing that list of all
the anime songs it's like opening
pandora's box
you're like which one do i sing
it's like and then the moment he
selected [ __ ] tell me why by the pen
pals i was just like
yeah okay the original the original
berserk
with the shittiest guitar riff in
existence i'm like
yeah hell yeah like it's already bad in
the original but then the karaoke
version was like oh
this is so much worse but it's so much
better it lasted at 3am we [ __ ]
destroyed that song more than it already
destroyed itself
like three times
i think it's back open though right from
what i understand yeah yeah
but it's hard to get in that mood you
know yeah i know
i know it's like i don't know like i
feel now that
we've all kind of been established here
it's like become a little bit more
difficult to just be like hey you want
to stay up till like 4 00 a.m to go to
karaoke
maybe because i get i go to bed at like
12 now i think i get really [ __ ]
tired earlier
like my sleep schedule's a lot healthier
now okay to explain another thing about
japanese drinking culture is that
you have this ticking clock and it's
called the last train and if you missed
the last train
you're staying out until 5am there's
there's there's no there's basically no
in-between either
you choose to go home at like what like
11 12 11 12
11 11 30 which to me is like if it was
just one hour later or like two hours
later it would be perfect
because after about one o'clock i'd be
like okay i've had my fun this is this
has been cool
i'm gonna catch the last train now but
like having to choose between going out
at uh like 11 30 when you're just about
getting to that point of drunkness that
you just want to keep your mind going
to staying up till 5 00 5 a.m which
we've done it several times
and every time i just feel more dead
inside i'm like
there is there is nothing worse i think
i think the only thing that is worse
than
going home while you're buzzed at 11 p.m
is
catching that first train at 4 30 just
like [ __ ] like
oh my god it's like sunny outside and
then like
this businessman next to you and you're
clearly a [ __ ] mess you just turn
into [ __ ] vampires
i [ __ ] fell asleep one time and
missed my stop by like an
hour i woke up at like 6 a.m like in
like
so [ __ ] northern like the end of the
line right yeah yeah i was like an
hour from like i think i was like an
hour and a half from tokyo yeah yeah
yeah
that's how far i'd gone and i was like
get back and i was so
[ __ ] done yeah i was it was like 6 30
a.m when i realized and i was like
no so i wanted to sleep
yeah i mean that's the tough thing man i
mean
that's the thing like back when i was
like still single
and like kind of going out and doing a
lot more of like the 4am 5am stuff
it would be a little bit easier because
you know say like a couple of my friends
would be like it'd be like you know one
or two a.m
and be like uh maybe we shouldn't
continue anymore it was really easy
because you could just go to a manga
cafe and just
book a [ __ ] room for like two three
hours yeah just [ __ ] sleep in there
until the first train
and that [ __ ] but we haven't done that
we should do that more often
instead of just being like let's let's
uh let's call up a taxi and spend 100
bucks to get home
i've always known that you can do the
manga cafes i just don't want to have
that conversation at 3am smashed
some japanese do drum like uh manga
yeah yeah hi
every single time it's been like i'll
just wait till 5am i'll just yeah
we should just do that from now on yeah
if we're having like a boys now we just
be like i don't want something because
sometimes
i don't want to spend a hundred bucks to
[ __ ] go coffee you know we're all
going back the same way it's time you
split it three ways i mean yeah
yeah still it's like you still feel like
[ __ ] behind
this side
[Music]
the clown is taking over this video is
sponsored by expressvpn
i know most of you are probably thinking
why don't i just use incognito mode
wrong gone you can't watch hentai
incognito mode or clear your browser
history as many times as you want it
doesn't
work wait you mean people actually know
what hentai i'm watching they see
the fbi possibly knows if they have an
interest
your internet service provider can see
every single website that you visit
that's why i
never go online without using expressvpn
it doesn't matter where you get your
internet from whether it be comcast
verizon or any other us isps
they can still legally sell all your
information to ad companies
i'm also told that expressvpn keeps all
of your information 100
safe with the most powerful encryption
available not that i would know any of
the other encryptions
expressvpn is also available on multiple
platforms you can have it on your phone
you can have it on your computer
tablet smart tv wherever you use the
internet expressvpn is there
i actually do use it and it's actually
really seamless it's this you're just
a single button press from my little
monkey brain what's going on dude you
notice it when it's on
no never i use it all the time and i do
often forget that i've put it on as it
doesn't really affect much i use it a
lot actually to get around like geo
restrictions for like netflix and stuff
like that sometimes there are like some
movies you just can't watch on like
japanese netflix whatever just
press a button it's on and get around
that [ __ ] it's also the number one rated
vpn service by cnet and wired
so you can visit our exclusive link at
expressvpn.com
trash taste get a free extra three
months for
free on a one year package that's
[Music]
e-x-p-r-e-s-s-vpn.com
trash taste now back to the episode you
know what i love about karaoke the most
though
sorry the clown juice
oh it's hidden it's hidden so
on top of the oil you can drink
sometimes they have like other stuff
that you can have like drink and eat
they'll have soft drinks but they might
have like soup sometimes
what yeah they have an ice cream yeah
about the ice cream during that [ __ ]
time when you guys like kind of stop
eating so much [ __ ] ice cream
because they came back with like two
[ __ ] pockets they had like
small tiny cups like bowls for this
this ice cream and i was like no i'll
take one of the big coke classes yeah
yeah [ __ ] pour all the ice cream in
there must have refilled it like three
or four times
but i was just sitting there the whole
whole time at karaoke sitting there just
the ice cream machine next to like the
soft drink machine
who the [ __ ] would get that like
yeah yeah but i i remember thinking like
i'm not we don't need that we need
alcohol yeah and then like
two hours later [ __ ] plastered i'm
like
coke float coke that sounds amazing
right now ice cream looks so good right
now it is
it is like pretty garbage vanilla ice
cream but
yeah but when you're like that drunk
it's like it's like you can get yeah you
don't put anything you could drink
anything
put anything in my body at that point
yo okay you know what else i like in
japan it just goes along with the
nightlife yeah right it's
the uconn drinks uh
explain that you can't drink because
that so i should have i should have
bought one in preparation if yeah
we can talk about this but there's these
like tiny little things like
200 milliliter cans yeah it's like a
medicine bottle
yeah yeah it tastes like bubble gum and
it's apparently like ginger like it
doesn't taste like bubble gum i think it
tastes like awesome i think it tastes i
think it tastes great
turmeric turmeric it looks like ginger
thank you melon but uh
yeah that tastes like i like do you like
i like i like the taste
felix liked the taste yeah but felix is
[ __ ] weird
it reminds me of calpol that's that's
why i like the taste so essentially what
this drink is advertised as
is uh prevents hangovers yeah and
everyone in the western world is like
that doesn't seem right
i'm pretty sure if it worked we would
that was my thought as well like how if
it really works
why has england's not used this before
don't you think the entire budget of the
nhs would be spent on buying this
because
then all of the medical problems would
be sold like i'm pretty sure we would
have it right yeah
i thought and then one day on a whim i
was like all right
fine i'll try it yeah and then it was
like having a shield
on your liver like none of the drinks
got me drunk
yeah yeah and it was like that for the
first few times until i really drank way
too much and then it was like
not drunk not drunk not drunk absolutely
unable to sleep
like not it's so weird it was just like
the 2020 economy it's just like
a corona virus tank and then you're
[ __ ] drunk
in like in like an instant because i
never tried it until i tried it with you
because every time i saw it i was like
no that maybe that will work for like
one drink yeah i don't go to a musical
and have one drink
so i'm like no this won't work for me
but then yeah i had it and
it tastes like us i'm like great this is
already a good start yeah and then yeah
i think i was like
four or five drinks you don't feel it
and i'm just like oh my god it's weird
the immunity
so like it's it's advertises that like
you don't have a hangover but
really i think you it's it's like
formatted alchemist it's like law of
equivalent exchange right
you drink it and you okay your [ __ ]
mother so you
you drink it and you get less drunk when
you're drinking it so you have to drink
more to get drunk but then the day after
like if you did completely destroy your
body i feel like it doesn't help in
hangover
if you go too hard it doesn't help but
you know those times where maybe you've
had like
quite a bit you're quite tipsy you're
not like absolutely shit-faced yeah it
like
completely stops any hangovers yeah
please stop any hangover but for me
it stops that tipsy feeling as well yeah
in my in my mind when it comes to like
whether it gets rid of the hangover the
next morning i feel like a lot of it is
just placebo
where it's just like if i drink this
it'll probably stop it and
i definitely definitely feel an effect
yeah because the hangovers
the worst hangovers i've had in japan is
when i haven't drank that right
so now i pretty much like you'll never
see me go like drinking without drinking
it now yeah which i don't know if it's a
good thing or not like is my body gonna
get dependent
on it to drink because like anything i
always drink it when i know i have
something to do the next day
it's not bad for you by the way it's
it's literally just like two americans
if anything is
very very healthy it's just a bunch of
like [ __ ] minerals and [ __ ] i don't
[ __ ] know what
like like look at me a monkey break like
i know what's in it
i'll question this [ __ ] just look it up
and you'll find it
yeah from what i understand it's it's
very healthy it's like a health drink
someone's going to come and be like
actually
yeah it's actually it destroys your
liver it's like as if the alcohol
doesn't already destroy them
hidden health benefits hidden health
benefits of course
oh my god what do you how do you boys
feel about
clubbing and because i've not been to a
club in japan before
yeah i've been to a few but i've never
enjoyed clubbing even even back in
australia
it was just never really a thing yeah i
don't i like bars but i don't like
i really like bars but i don't like club
i feel like
okay here's here's my theory i feel like
clubbing is this place that everyone's
convinced themselves they enjoy when
they really don't enjoy
like it's clubbing is one massive lie i
don't know anyone who actually enjoys
clubbing
because the only time you enjoy clubbing
is if you're massively plastic if you
actually enjoy clubbing
you're someone i don't want to talk to
people the people i know who enjoy
clubbing are not me the ones who i just
don't like hanging out with yeah yeah i
know i'm not going to like the epitome
of oh my god
they always talk like it's like clubbing
is like clubbing is great
when you're like young i guess but then
you you reach a certain point
like a few years past and you realize
man i'd never really enjoy clubbing
isn't it
i was just lying to myself all i do when
i go to a club
is go in see the dance floor order a
drink go go dancing for like five
minutes realize i'm still too sober go
order another drink
and then that cycle repeats repeat until
you're [ __ ] drunk enough to not
remember the night
and if you do remember the night it's a
[ __ ] night yeah right and it hurts
because like you've got to pay entry fee
yeah and then you've got to pay like
double the price for a drink so if
you're not drunk enough it's like [ __ ]
not only am i
my am i having a [ __ ] time my wallet is
taking a financial beating
clubs are fast man they're a lie yeah
i'll tell you the only times clubbing is
fun but
can i tell the story about the last time
we went club sure sure go ahead
okay i feel like the only time clubbing
is actually fun
is when the night isn't planned when you
when you don't plan to go to a club i
feel like
like the spontaneous clubbing nights are
the best because you're already really
drunk and in the mood
when when you just suddenly decide to go
to a club so the last time
i've actually went clubbing was like
over a year ago yeah with uh and it was
with connor and two of my mates right
and it was just a spontaneous kind of
clubbing night where we didn't even plan
to go clubbing we just wanted to go hit
up some bars
and then we got massively i think we
were just sitting at your house and we
were just gonna do that
and yeah i think someone brought it up
and we were like clubbing
i i i think the i think we were we were
like we were sitting in the house and we
were just gonna have like a chilled
night right we were telling stories
about clubbing we were telling stories
about clubbing and i think eventually we
were like should we just
go clubbing yeah because i remember we
hit up a bar beforehand and we were like
pretty we were pretty uh we were pretty
merry at that point we weren't super
drunk
and then we got to the bar i think it
was like absolute like absolutely vodka
in brighton or something
and we just ordered like three of those
14 shot trays oh my god
and we got drunk very very fast but
the person who got drunk the most was
this guy
i think i had like one of the whole like
14 shots to myself
and i'm like bear in mind i think i was
just i i
[Music]
said at the time i just like broke up
with my ex and i was like i just want to
go out i just want to come here
i just want to do something i want to
get out of here it happens yeah i was
like i almost want to party and then i
went i went waiting so what was the last
memory you had that night i remember
waiting in line for the club
alcohol abuse is bad by the way yeah we
don't condone this
this is a story not condoning we're
laughing about it
i've rarely rarely do i get that drunk
where i
don't remember exactly what happened
which is which i when i speak to
americans like that sounds scary i'm
like yeah
yeah i mean i'm around my mates you know
they'll take care of me so after the bar
we clearly realized how drunk connor was
but we still it was still like pretty
early in the night it was like
it was like 10 o'clock 10 30. the club
had just opened but that's
that's kind of the timing we're talking
about and we're kind of we're all like
okay
before the alcohol gets connor anymore
we gotta [ __ ] get in this club as
soon as possible
so we line up just as the club was
opening never mind it's like a [ __ ]
wednesday or something
yeah yeah yeah no one was clubbing no
one
it was like us we were worried about how
connor was gonna get in because he was
clearly
over the [ __ ] limit and if you know
uk clubs if you look like you're too
drunk i'll be fine they're just not
going to let you win bounces
bouncers in the uk are like the but the
school bully like yeah
they're like they will take advantage of
any power they have
so we're [ __ ] worried so somehow
connor we managed to get connor in
this club okay this is the best heist
movie yeah yeah
so we managed to get connor and we're
like oh that's this is it we've done it
we've been with you
we've done mission impossible yeah yeah
so then we go over
to the bar as you do in the clubbing
experience the first thing you go to
is the bar of course and then we go to
order our drinks and so i'm here with
two of my mates
and we we each order a drink and then we
look around
and connor's just not there we're like
wait if you're not with connor
and you're not with connor and i'm not
with connor
then where the [ __ ] connor and then we
turn around
and look at this like look at this empty
dance floor
right and connor is just standing there
at a 90 degree angle he's like this
and then we're like oh [ __ ] we better
get him off the dance floor and then
like as we're walking over
he starts [ __ ] fortnite dancing by
himself on the dance floor
and you know what you got to do you got
to do it and so
the bouncer sees this and obviously
connor's like way over the limit so
he gets kicked out and so we we also we
also have to follow him out the club so
we're like
do we attempt another club it's only
like 10 30. let's try and attempt
another club
thinking we're not gonna get in somehow
connor by pure instinct
he's like he's like he can't even walk
to this next club but as soon as he's
standing in line he's like
yes gentlemen yeah i don't know i don't
know why when i'm drunk for some reason
i can just like for like
30 seconds i could be like yes of course
yes i don't know why like it's a
superpower
yeah like when you're when he's in front
of the bouncer he just turns into like
proper sea dog va yeah the monkey brain
unlocks into human brain so then we
somehow
we somehow get him to get him into the
second club okay
and the same [ __ ] thing happens again
we're going to the bar and then we take
our eyes off corner for one second
order our drink i look around look to my
look to my left
look to my right if you're not with god
we all know we've got and then we turn
around and once again
connor on an empty dance floor is just
fortnite dancing by himself is that just
like an instinct for you to do
like so i think it must be i like
dancing i don't know why fortnite
dancing must be my go-to
i don't know and so we get kicked out of
that club and that was the end of the
night oh my god
good night it's good night good night
yeah he he woke up
don't get that drunk yeah he uh he we
got him back home
uh i took him on the bed and he just
started snuggling inside the saggy
pillow
and yeah that's what he woke up all the
instincts are getting unlocked
yeah i woke up and i was like where is
my phone and wallet
where is it and then it was just under
the bed but i was like that's like the
first five minute panic of my i was like
where is it oh my god so you don't
remember any of that
i remember some of it but not much yeah
i mean that was probably the most drunk
i've gotten in a very long time i rarely
ever get that drunk
yeah but you know sometimes you [ __ ] up
and do a lot of vodka and uh
what happens man because like you've
you've been clubbing in japan
right yeah yeah what's that like how
does it compare to the rest of the world
it's just like at least compared to the
uk right in the uk i feel like everyone
in the club is very drunk and in japan i
felt like everyone was in the same
situation of
i need to be drunker which makes a
really shitty club environment because
everyone's kind of sober and it's weird
yeah
yeah no almost like step out of line
yeah it's weird like no one's doing
anything fun
except like for somehow everyone is
really well behaved
and somehow the moment you step into the
toilet it was like a war zone in that
toilet i don't know what happened
there was a dude who was like pissing
and he was not even aiming in the urinal
he was aiming at the wall next to it and
it was spraying
and i i remember walked in and i'm like
i'm not getting blamed for this i'm
walking yeah
because i know this guy was japanese and
i'm like i'm not [ __ ] with it
i don't want to be blamed for this i'm
not doing it i'm the minority in this
club
i'm like i'm the foreigner here i'm not
getting i'm walking out right now
yeah but yeah there it was so filthy but
the rest of the club was just like
fine it was whatever it was just a
depressing situation
you know i'd rather have been smashed
fortnite dancing alone
any day of the week yeah yeah that's
that's kind of a similar experience i
had i went to one club in japan and that
was enough for me to be like
yeah i mean i never really enjoyed clubs
but i was like you know what i'm
living here i might as well give it a go
yeah i just wasn't it
i felt like everyone was doing it
because they've seen it in the movies
there i don't know why
everyone's like this is cool right yeah
right now right like
we've seen this in the movies right this
is exactly how we're supposed to behave
right because i i think the like the
most different clubbing experience i've
had is probably in thailand
but they have like i i don't like i like
their club and culture even less
right because they don't even have a
dance floor so some clubs in thailand
um it's you go in and there's no dance
floor but everyone has their own tables
but the music is just as loud as any
other club
so try and see so you're sitting in a
loud restaurant this is a loud bar right
everyone has these private tables so you
can't even like it's not a social
environment where you can go
meet other people or even like like
interact with other people
you're with your mates but it's so loud
that you can't communicate with
roommates
so all you're doing is sitting in this
loud [ __ ] room i must sound like such
an old guy now
the music was too loud this was awful
but no no
too fair when the music is too loud it's
like my biggest pet peeve yeah like i'm
just like
i've been in some clubs in australia
where the base is so
[ __ ] bass boosted that you can
actually hear feel your chest going
dude it's like this while you're sitting
there i was like hey how are you
my voice is so bassy as well that in
clubs like i could just cannot
communicate
like it just gets drowned i remember
like university if i ever tried to like
hit
on someone they'd just be like what are
you saying
do you have that thing where you're
trying to say something to your mate but
it's so loud
so you sue or your mate's trying to say
something to you and it just sounds like
and you're like uh sorry can you say
that again you do you do it like three
times as the magic number
and then the third time you're like yeah
oh yeah yeah yeah definitely yeah
i'd be like yeah i don't know i don't
know whatever they say
that's just yeah that's just the
clubbing experience yeah i guess i mean
we personally don't recommend
clubs in japan but i mean i mean okay if
that's weird if that's your stick that's
actually
we don't we've i think we've made it
clear that we don't really like clubbing
anyway so we're
not going to enjoy like japan the reason
i like izakaya
is that it's the perfect social
environment because i like talking to
people i like house parties i like house
parties
like i've always in university if
there's a choice between a clubbing
going clubbing going to a house party
i'm like
100 of the time i'm choosing the house
because i like talking to people and
i feel like the izakaya vibe is just
that perfect vibe that
yes just like you allows you to talk to
your mates there's also that element of
a house party it's like are they gonna
[ __ ] up their own house if someone i
want to be there to watch this it's like
the craziest house party
you guys have been to okay i've got like
i've got like two and they were both in
university because of course they were
of course they were
do you have one i mean i can only really
think of like if
i have one if you want me to go first
there's a lot of like poop stories but
i'm like
yeah this is where the poop stories are
yeah
all of my poop stories come from house
parties what who's
what like uh okay so in australia oh my
god what
another thing about this was [ __ ]
disgusting but oh no no no
but uh do you know what a shoei is
that's why you do the
the beer out of the shoe yeah so it's
this thing that's very typical in
australia because there's nothing
why is this typical an australian
typical house party yeah
but essentially what it is is you it's
kind of like shotgunning in america
right where
shotgunning is like you know if
someone's holding a can of beer they're
like oh shotgun it so you poke a hole on
the side and then you kind of drink
the whole thing like this chewy is that
but way grosser you
you say hey do a shoei and then you go
around the tradition is you go around
and find whoever has the dirtiest
[ __ ] shoe oh
it's not just any shoe it's whoever has
the dirty shirt it's either you do your
own shoe
or you pick whoever is dirty it's
already starting horribly
and then you grab their shoe you pour
the can of beer into their shoe and then
you drink the beer from their shoe and
that's
disgusting and i mean it's not that
exciting of a story but
my friend did a shoei once and he got
his friend's uh
shoe and he didn't realize until after
he finished the shoei that he had
stepped on his dog
[ __ ] so he had like a firm grasp he had
a firm grasp of it
and he finished it and he's like he
flipped it over he just saw like [ __ ]
just smeared on them and like normal
people will be like oh what the [ __ ] but
because he was already so ham and he's
just like
and everyone was like yeah this is
[ __ ] nasty
that's that's the only thing really and
then other than that it's just like a
lot of like
vomit stories you know the usual thing
here at house parties yeah
i mean yeah that was probably the
grossest but also the most hilarious
oh my god we're at uconn i mean i've
been to like a few crazy house parties
uh i think most of the crazy house
parties i've been to has been in
brighton
yeah so that's like my hometown um there
are some parties that are just like
kind of like you know that scene from
american pie where you see that scene
you're like there's no way that
that exists in real life there's no way
this crazy shit's happening yeah
but yeah i've been to a few parties
where it was actually that crazy so i
remember one time
where there was this there was this
party who we'd heard from a friend who
heard from another friend who heard from
another friend no that kind of that kind
of thing that's
been into a horse that there was a party
happening in the middle of this field
i'm just like there's no [ __ ] way
this is true so
we had to drive into the middle of
[ __ ] nowhere and i was like
this is a scam we're gonna we're gonna
drive there and there's just gonna be
like
it's just gonna be like a drug dealer
then or something yeah this is gonna be
like
we're gonna we're gonna get [ __ ]
murdered yeah and so
we drive to the middle of this field and
and this keep in mind this is all pitch
black because it's like the middle of
the country
where we're driving to so we can see
[ __ ] and then we go there and it was
basically like a festival
somehow they had managed to because this
guy who had owned the farm
right had just had just told a few of
his mates that he was going to have a
party
right and then mate started telling
mates and then
that's always the worst yeah i don't
know how it spreads so wide
right jesus but i feel like it's because
no one else is having a party that
weekend and people were just egging
like people were just i really wanted to
go somewhere
i needed a party and yeah somehow there
was a [ __ ] festival
and then things started getting weird
they started saying things on fire
right so so they went into
his house right and then they took out
this sofa
and somebody thought it would be a fun
idea to just start burning stuff
so it started why is always one person i
there's always one
pirate one [ __ ] pyromaniac right
and so first it starts with a chair so
they get they get a chair out right i'm
like okay let's set this on fire and
it's like
it's like [ __ ] caveman mode activates
like whenever
whenever you start to fire for some
reason like
you see fire and then you're like oh
fire and then like you start [ __ ]
dancing around
like oh fire i don't know why whenever
there's a fire in there like a house
party and there's alcohol involved
you just forget the lizard brain just
takes over and you just
you just like circling just watch it
yeah and then so they burn they burn the
chair down and they were like
what can we do next what can we do next
next let's get a table
so so out of nowhere just take this
guy's whole [ __ ] ikea collection
like jesus so then they take a table
they set that on fire then as that's on
fire a [ __ ] sofa appears out of
nowhere
and then they [ __ ] just chuck the
sofa in and then we were just like
at the back of my mind i'm thinking man
the host must feel so [ __ ] [ __ ] like
i don't know where he's probably passing
out his mind oh my furniture
and then as the sofa is on fire we
actually see the host
just walk out and he just looks at this
so his sofa and like his [ __ ] ikea
furniture collection that's on fire
and just goes yeah what if right what if
all along you planned this out right
because in the uk if you want to get rid
of stuff like that you've got to pay a
lot
yeah so maybe this was all a ploy just
so he could get new sofas and shares and
not pay to remove his old ones
yeah there's always also that one guy in
any kind of situation like that where
something's put on fire where they're
like holding a
alcoholic beverage and they're like i
wonder what happens if i pour it off
like this will probably put it out right
it just makes the flame bigger it's like
oh
i was expecting that okay every time
every [ __ ] time animals yeah [ __ ]
cavemen
there was a so you know how i said i
lived in like a student village yeah
yeah it was basically a whole area that
was just houses and they had
also two really big uh like apartment
blocks and they were disgusting they
were like the cheapest apartment blocks
you could imagine
and uh one time people this doesn't
exist anymore this place they tore it
all down
uh so yeah swansea student village r.i.p
um
they said like oh yeah there's gonna be
a party at one of the apartment
buildings they didn't say which floor or
anything so i thought that was kind of
weird
yeah and then we turn up and like half
of this apartment building there's like
bin bags
on all the windows right and stuff and
then you start going into this building
and it's like been turned into like the
set of the raid
like there's just [ __ ] everywhere like
there's mattresses on the floor and [ __ ]
like
all over the place and some of the rooms
are open and have like nothing left in
them and i'm like
what the [ __ ] meanwhile everyone is like
drunk as [ __ ]
there's like people doing drugs in
certain places yeah people in the
kitchen there's always that one guys in
the kitchen making food for some reason
these parties like this building is
literally like falling apart and one
guy's stealing
pizza yeah any beans
it was just weird and it was like the
further up you went the like
more mess it was and i remember going to
one floor and there was just like
beds all over it and people lying down
and i'm like what the [ __ ] is going on
here
that was just weird and then i just
didn't enjoy it because i'm like what is
this wait wait so what was the
was like an orgy floor or like what i
didn't how did you get invited to this
party it was one of those things where
everyone in like just everyone knew it
was happening yeah in the village
apparently so we all just turned down
the village
around the village just like this
building here and i was like i was like
what why did you put uh
my ass one of the guys like why they put
bin bags on the windows
and they were like oh so they can't see
what's going on inside i'm like who
who can't see because i think putting
black wind
like blacking out all the windows is
suspicious giving it away right yeah
that's what i thought and also a bunch
of people migrating towards this one
thing
they completely [ __ ] it though i don't
know what happened to it or how how this
was even possible i'm sure one might use
i mean the fact that it's gone now
yeah yeah and then there was a another
party which is really weird and it was a
house party like just a normal house
and had a bouncer which i thought was
really weird when i had the house
at a house party and i thought it was
[ __ ] loaded
right right so it was a three-story
house not that big but i thought wow
this is [ __ ] weird there's a bounty
here the list
i said my name's like you're on the list
and i'm like when did i get put on the
list
what is this i was like who's arranging
this list because my friend invited me
so
he must have put me on the list and i
got inside
the first floor just is like a big
living room just has one
small couch in the corner and like a
hundred people just standing around this
like
very average looking laminated like wood
floor just
people just standing around i'm like
what the [ __ ] why is there a bouncer
and then you go up the floors and it
starts to get weird yeah and of course
it does whenever you go up floors in
these weird house parties
everybody asked i found out that i asked
my friend he was like oh yeah i paid the
mountain like 300 pounds just for
tonight
and i'm like why why why what would you
expect
to happen are you that worried and then
okay okay to be fair and then i realized
why he was that worried because the
second floor was just people having sex
that's actually pretty standard that's
pretty standard that's pretty standard
yeah i was like whatever and i was like
okay
i'm gonna show because the bottom floor
was just really loud maybe i want to go
to the floor people who's just chatting
yeah yeah right so i go to the third
floor
and that's where it gets really [ __ ]
weird because one of the rooms
is like uh what i thought it was was
like five beds two bunk beds and instead
they just put all the mattresses on the
floor
i don't know why people are doing this
yeah all the mattresses were on the
floor and like people were making out
and one of them had like uh was doing
like a needle i don't know what he was
doing and i was like oh this is weird
this is really [ __ ] weird i'm not
going here and so i was like
i asked my friend i'm like there's got
to be somewhere else we can go i do not
want to stay here there is someone doing
what i think is heroin upstairs yeah can
we can we not do this yeah
university is a mess jesus christ i've
never had any like that because i hung
out with good christian boys
well no sure do i but sometimes you go
to a party right cause you hear about a
party right you don't know what it's
gonna be like till you get there yeah
until you see someone doing like
hardcore drugs upstairs and you're like
i'm not supposed to be here i i don't do
that
i need to go to church with the house
parties the more stays you go up is like
the closer you get to hell it's like the
steps towards hell it's literally the
raid it's like the opposite right it's
like the further up you go the closer
you get to hell
because i mean you have no way of
knowing in the uk what the party's going
to be like to
get there if your friend's like dead set
on going you're like all right fine
because i've been to as many like dad
parties where you go to and it's like
this isn't a party this is a house
gathering
yeah yeah with with like prettied up
we're freaking out
right you never know a party could mean
like a come dine with me four people
making dinner for each other
or it could be you know a [ __ ] orgy
going on upstairs yeah you don't know
until you get there
jesus christ no one knows my parents are
probably terrified they're like
what was conor doing in university i was
not doing anything mother
i was just you happen to go to places
and they [ __ ] up yeah it's funny
because i did i had less crazy
parties in university but that might
just be because of the university i went
to which was like yeah
university of bristol and because it's
like a city campus it's like university
britain was
bristol was like in the middle of the
city there was like less going on
because
it was all like we're integrated with
the normal people yeah yeah
not more working people so you can get
away with less [ __ ] than if it was on
like a couch
yeah mine was kind of the same because
sydney uni was in like the smack bang
middle of like the city center in sydney
so
i mean there was always weird [ __ ] that
were happening in like the smaller
campuses but
nothing like that there was just so many
run down places so it was like sometimes
i think like locals would like
see a party and then just like go in
yeah i think that happened a lot
yeah that makes sense that's why i would
never throw a house party that just let
anyone in
no no i don't know bro talk about the
trust system bro you
that's just that's like the other end of
it like a stupid trust like i remember
if you were having a party and you
thought like
you told your close mates especially in
my school because this was like before
when i went to university but like in
like in like college
if you if there was a party everyone
everyone in [ __ ] brighton would not
know about yeah
you know word would get out and i would
not throw a party especially on a day
like new year's eve where everyone's
searching for right right yeah people
just rock up
just yeah i mean that's kind of why i
just kind of don't go to like open
invite house parties anymore
because after seeing that i'm like
that's just too much that's
i i'm not i'm not signing up for that i
don't need that in mind yeah it's like
if i wanted to go to a house party and
like four fifths of the people there are
people i don't know i rather just go to
a club yeah
yeah it's basically it becomes the same
thing right yeah like clubs are pretty
bad but at least there's
not people doing like [ __ ] [ __ ]
on the dance floor probably in the
toilet that's them i don't care
even fortnite dance yeah kind of a
fortnite dance without people judging me
and me in the orgy room fortnite
oh the mattress is a dance floor dance
right yeah
oh my god oh my god but uh have you guys
ever been to the uh i know it's a proper
like tourist trap or whatever it's
considered by the the golden guy in
shinjuku
oh yeah i've been i've been a fan would
you like it no no not your thing not
really can i explain what golden guy is
yeah so golden guy is like this [ __ ]
what is like 40 by 40 meters
area if you will and it's just like a
series of alleyways extremely compact
it's not even a block
it's like it's within the block isn't it
yeah it's tiny and these bars all seat
max three to four people sometimes two
yeah um depending on where you go
and uh it's really expensive you pay
like sometimes like
10 bucks just to sit down and then you
only pay like 10 bucks for a drink
um and yeah it's a tourist trap because
a lot of the time it's tourists and also
it's a very sketchy area yeah yeah and
if you are a foreigner there will be a
guy who is very much watching you
yeah the moment they see your foreign
they'll come up to you it's really
[ __ ] frustrating
yeah i went in there once uh just
because i wanted to take my friend who
had never yeah so i was like okay i'll
experience it and yeah i was just like
man this is just like a really
cramped super expensive drinking
experience that you can get
anywhere else it's like if you see
pictures of it which will probably
be on screen now it's it's kind of like
cyberpunk house cloud like i love going
to golden gate just to take photos
yeah it's it's like that cyberpunk
aesthetic where you just got these all
a lot of these buildings and a lot of
these bars just like cramped together
and you don't even know how anyone could
live in there let alone operate a
business in here
because i can't imagine any of these
bars getting maybe more than like
10 people across like a night right uh
it depends there's one or two of the
bars that are decently big but most of
them are yeah like
i mean there's like a few big ones like
outside of golden gate like right before
you enter it like near the entrance but
like when once you actually go
into golden gai it's like how do any of
these places stay open
i think it's you i think you go to
golden gai
to meet other people right you don't go
there with your
well you can go there with your members
you can also meet other people anywhere
else
but there's this kind of vibe to it
that's like because it's so small
right like you immediately have to talk
to anyone who's next to you yeah like
you don't really have a choice
like in the rest of tokyo you kind of go
out your way and be like hi you want to
know about my cult
right like you got like really you've
got to pray yeah yeah you've got to seem
like a little weird
right because yeah but in this bar you
know you sit down you're immediately
next to someone and you start trying to
communicate and
yeah the one time i went was because um
i was staying right next to it funny
enough
and i think it was one night where uh
it's my second to last night in japan my
first time visiting
i think joey joey like gone and allen
didn't want to hang out and i was like
well i want to do something so
i googled i'm like where can i go and
then this was the only place that came
up and i was like
fine i've never heard of it before i
didn't know it was a tourist trap right
yeah so i just went there
and uh yeah it was really fun i mean met
a ton of people and then
eventually made friends with these like
japanese people who took me to someone
like the japanese only bars
yeah and that was really fun because
then they were all talking to me asking
what my favorite anime was
knowing the japanese titles came in very
handy that day oh yeah of course
yeah it's just a lot of fun i mean when
it works and you go out and you meet
people and they're actually cool and
it's fun it's like
the best thing ever i feel like you got
a quite a lucky experience though
especially in golden gai because i think
so yeah i've heard a lot of like horror
stories about goals
i think a lot you could easily go there
and just have not mean anything for the
worst time
and yet spend a lot of money because
i've been to like quite a few
like smaller bars and establishments
that are outside like just outside of
the
guy this is really [ __ ] cool uh
gaming bar that chris broad took me to
yeah
like literally across the road from
golden guy yeah one up or
zero i think he's called one up yeah
i've been there yeah yeah yeah yeah and
it's it's tiny like
there's just one bar can only maybe seat
like you know six people yeah but
like it's like a proper game but we're
not talking about the one thing you guys
looking to in the uk
right it's like a legit like gaming bar
and that one was really [ __ ] cool and
way way cheaper than golden guy but the
problem is that those kinds of
places don't come up in google searches
right it's almost always like where do
you drink and change
golden guy always comes yeah i noticed
there's like a lot of bars in japan
[ __ ] tiny and you go in there and
it's like i really like the vibe because
it's like a really intimate vibe because
it can only fit like five to six people
and there's only like one bar and you
see at the counter um
but i do like that vibe and i don't know
how they stay in business because there
are so many in japan
and they're so hidden away yeah there's
so many like like the cigar bar we went
to an
ikebukuro right now it was like how the
[ __ ] would anyone be like yes let me go
into this tiny building go
all the way up to the sixth floor and
there it is right there it's like
how would you how would you know that
that's yeah yeah right it's it's like it
could be
just someone's apartment before we know
it probably is something that they just
remodeled that's kind of like the size
we're talking about
yeah uh like like an apartment in tokyo
just just yeah like a one-room apartment
yeah
yeah well you jumped to that bar that
was like it was like an apartment
someone's apartment in an apartment
building that had been converted into a
penguin oh yeah
yeah and i was like what the [ __ ] is
this and yeah they said food and
everything it was [ __ ] weird so that
sydney actually discovered that because
she read a manga that i was based on
like a manga that had that bar in it and
she googled and that bar actually
existed so it's this
it's this ping pong bar that has like
this massive ping pong table in the
middle it's like going into someone's
living room
to get there like we had to go down the
dodgiest alleyway right it was literally
this
hand written sign that says ping pong
bar go down this alleyway
and so we go down this alleyway it's
like a it's like some [ __ ] from pt
right like there could be someone doing
heroin around the corner you had no
[ __ ] clue
uh so we go in there and then we had to
go up these stairs and it was just like
the
stone stairs that someone's probably
pissed on you know
yeah so we go up and then it's just
someone's apartment
it's just literally someone's apartment
but you but then
they open the door and it's like a
proper they've probably remodeled it
into a bar
and i'm thinking man how would anyone
[ __ ] discover this because this is
just
hidden away down two [ __ ] dodgy
alleys that i would not go down
that's what i'm saying it's like there
are so many where i'm just like you
wouldn't if you didn't have a curious
mind
and you weren't afraid that you might
possibly get stabbed down this alleyway
there are so many places where it's just
like you'd never be able to see it i
mean
yeah that's why i think shinjuku is good
especially if you're a foreigner because
you can
i think a lot of people in shinjuku are
like wanting to meet foreigners and
stuff like that or shibuya
so if you stay to those two places yeah
they're super touristy and everyone
knows about them
but i think a lot of places outside of
that you probably won't find people who
are super eager to talk to foreigners
maybe maybe maybe yeah but that's as far
as you'll probably go right
yeah i mean in shinjuku you'll
definitely find people who want to speak
to you if you're a foreigner
and like sometimes you go to a bar and
like the people serving you
have to have to speak to you as well
yeah that's fun yeah i like that
experience like the
one place we went to that started
playing all of our youtube videos
so there was this bar that we went to
right there was this bar that we went to
it like a really small intimate bar
um and they've i can't remember who
brought up the conversation but i
remember
they found out that sydney was a
youtuber because sydney was there as
well right
and she makes the stupid mistake of
telling her her youtube channel
so this bar has like four like has like
about
three tvs in it right and so
as soon as the bard lady hears her
youtube channel she just like chromecast
sydney's [ __ ] cities videos
sydney's video all over the bar where
like other people are also drinking
there
so we're just there watching silly's
youtube channel
and she's she's just like dying inside
that's a [ __ ] nightmare isn't it
that's the one thing you shouldn't do
if you have a youtuber friend is play
their videos in front of them oh yeah
exactly what is it about that
i've never understood just hearing your
own voice or you being
not like being silly right yeah yeah but
it's just like
it's like you're okay with you it's such
a weird dilemma because
my cousin asked me that same question
where she's like okay so you're all fine
with me watching your videos
as long as you're not there but the
moment you're there you don't want me
watching the video like how does that
make sense i'm just like
i don't know i just don't like it
exactly
yeah like i hate it when i have to
re-watch my video to like
check it like i'm fine with that are you
yeah cause i'm just like man
i used to not be and then now i'm like
god i love this video
god i love you god i love that i loved
it i love this part damn it connor
damn that was a funny joke connor i'm
proud of you yeah i don't mind
re-watching
back on my video that i'm editing for
example if i'm the only one in the room
but if someone's standing behind me like
micromanaging me and watching other
people like please leave
i don't want you watching this right now
you can go watch it after it's uploaded
yeah when i'm not there
yeah i don't get it it's weird do you
remember the time
that you accidentally deleted the video
while we were out drinking
oh my god
because what happened was we were at a
friend's house yeah and they they were
chromecast and all my [ __ ] videos to
the chromecast
and i don't want to watch my videos this
is about 2 2 a.m in the night so we were
pretty drunk at this point
and um so [ __ ] bad so it was my most
recent video and had a sponsor on it
yeah right
and so here's what here's what here's
what happens right when you have the
youtube app and someone's chromecasting
and you're also connected
you can like uh like move the video like
skip it whatever
and it said like oh like i could click
on the playlist of the cued videos
and it said uh i clicked it and my video
was on i was like i want to turn this
off so
i click it and there's no off button
there's any delete video and i was like
well
delete video from the chromecast
so i deleted the video on the spot bear
in mind i haven't been paid for the
sponsor yet
and it got paid like and i just blowed
it like two days ago
yeah and then i i was i realized like 10
minutes later i'm like i'm looking on my
channel i'm like
where's the video going wait
wait did i delete the video and then i
was just sitting there for like all
night sobering up just thinking like i
deleted the [ __ ] video what am i
going to do maybe they won't notice
the video and then on the on the taxi
back which was gone i was like
gone i think i [ __ ] up what do i do i
deleted the sponsor video i don't know
how do i
how do i play the results recently
i remember connor telling me it's like
yeah i think i deleted a video i'm like
oh
i mean so that's not that bad right just
re-upload it and he's like
no i mean it's a sponsored video and i
haven't been paid for it yet
and do you think the sponsors will
notice i'm just like
ah okay that's that's a pickle that
you're in
a bit of a pickle and then like they i
can't remember who which sponsor it was
pretty sure they probably shouldn't tell
anyone because they don't want to yeah
uh they emailed me like two days after
they were like hey uh
where's the video coming where's it gone
and luckily i've just been dealing with
a channel like copyright issues
yeah and so i emailed the mac and being
like oh gosh darn it that youtube
copyright
doing its magic again they've blocked
the video worldwide as i'm like retyping
all the things
i'm like i'm pretty sure i can fix it by
tomorrow at 8 a.m
and so i uploaded it and they're like
great work connor back up and i'm like
thank you man i'm so glad i fixed it i
was like oh my god
i couldn't be there so yeah i was really
drunk i wasn't i wasn't even that drunk
i wasn't even telling you i was just
like
really dumb i was just really [ __ ]
dumb i just did it and i was like [ __ ]
that's a bad thing can you please play
me
oh my god i got paid for it in the end
though that's good that's a youtuber's
worst nightmare
yeah delivering a video not so bad but
having to explain to someone like why
are you delighted yeah
i think it's it's like you know when you
have to explain to your parents that you
[ __ ] up in some kind of yeah
yeah and you're like man i really i
really have to hype myself up to uh just
explain to mum and dad why
this thing has happened oh my god that's
terrible but going back to uh
japan nightlife yeah how do we keep
going off on these [ __ ] tangents it's
fun let the tangents happen jerry all
the fun
i'm okay with it i'm okay i'm just i'm
just impressed at ourselves that we can
tangent that [ __ ] far away from
whatever it is that we're talking about
but one place i like to go to a lot is
baggis
oh yeah i like baggers too have you been
in baggage i have not been
okay because i was saying before that i
was like i don't i didn't remember it
was you or connor who hasn't been to
baggage
i've been back but yeah so baggage to
explain
is uh it's like a darts pull
ping pong there's more other stuff as
well it depends on like something it's a
mango cafe as well so basically
where i did the mango cafe video that's
a baggis so they have a bunch of
different baggages sometimes they focus
on the manga cafe side of things
sometimes they focus on the pool and
darts bar side of things but
basically it's this like 24 7
establishment that's
where you can just go and like get
drinks and just hang out and you know
play pool and stuff like that there's a
town in shinjuku in shibuya yeah yeah a
lot
a lot but uh i'm surprised you haven't
been i don't know i don't think
that's yeah i don't know i just haven't
been yeah it's a
i think it's one of those places because
you want to spend at least two to three
hours there
and you don't you don't really want to
do it before your meal you don't really
want to do it after your meal because
that's like best drinking hours
yeah so it's normally like you know it
gets to 1am you're like what do you guys
want to do i don't want to keep drinking
that much
yeah yeah exactly it's fine i mean it's
kind of pricey though
it is a little if you're there for like
three hours that [ __ ] adds up fast
because they charge you per
half an hour half an hour and then
you're buying drinks on top which the
drinks are kind of a little pricey i
mean you can get all you can drink
though of course can you
i don't even know that yeah you can do
all you can drink in a bag yeah again
you have to be prepared to stay for like
at least two hours right yeah because i
know they do a package that's like
the till the sun like comes up yeah yeah
yeah it's like
one to six a.m yeah and it's quite cheap
but obviously you're committing yeah but
it's like
it's like i'm going to stay up till 6
a.m to play pool there's only so much
pool you can play before you're like
this just isn't fun anymore
we both we both aren't good at pool and
we've been doing it for 30 minutes and
i'm starting to think i don't like this
i i feel like i get better when i'm
drinking apple yeah i don't know that's
the alcohol making you think you're
better
no no it's not that you're getting
better your opponent which was just as
drunk as you was getting worse
so for some i think i just doubt myself
too much where
when when i'm like playing pool sober
but i think when i'm like about two
pints in i just like
start hitting shots i'm like for some
reason it just goes in
and then i have four drinks and then i
start getting worse again i don't know
like i feel like there's a sweet spot
where the where i'm like slightly tipsy
and i'm like a [ __ ] god at pool
i'm like that with bowling i like their
darts because it's not a dart board it's
like an arcade machine with a dart board
it's like yes it's like an electric
some of them are so [ __ ] overkill and
what they are like there was one more
like you could play a whole rpg
in dark yeah that's right i don't
remember i was like what the [ __ ] is
this
and it was like your dart would do x
amount of damage yeah yeah yeah
and it's so hard with a straight face
like if you're on a date or something
being like hey do you want to you want
to play the rpg dog
that sounds amazing that's pretty great
for the first time but then some of the
levels were so
[ __ ] you had to get like you needed
to be like a [ __ ] yeah you had to get
like triple 20s like
every single one i mean this is [ __ ]
medusa should die way easier than this
come on yeah but like it's it's those
little touches right that i think add to
the whole like
bags it is a lot more fun that you don't
have to count in the dark because the
machine just does it for you exactly
exactly it does make it a lot longer
i've been to like a lot of old-fashioned
pubs in
australia where like yeah there is like
a dark but you get the real darts into
those pops
they have these like [ __ ] but it's
also like plastic dots yeah but it's
also like just as dangerous as well
i love it
joey no i'm good man it's all for that
[ __ ] i mean you meet these people in the
uk that are like
four pints in and getting they get like
the peak performance out of four pints
yeah it's insane i'm like that with
bowling i [ __ ] suck at bowling while
i'm sober but i've
quickly discovered the other day that if
i drink like two or three pints
before bowling i can do like a [ __ ]
turkey like no tomorrow
because you just don't think you just
like throw balls
i don't know why but i think bowling is
like the most depressing activity out of
all of the activities
really i think so i feel like bowling
with alcohol
is fun it's fine but bowling without
alcohol is
boring i think i feel like i like
bowling because
i don't didn't really play it growing up
yeah like i know like this
it's it's you're either the kid who
[ __ ] used to bowl all the freaking
time for fun
or you were that one kid who would only
ever bowl like balls for fun
a lot of people do in the uk apparently
do they yeah why do you think bowling's
depressing
i don't know there's an air to it
they're always it just doesn't hit
different
okay so i went okay this isn't an
exclusive incident a lot of the places
are like this but i'm just giving this
for an example
i went to a place in california right
very nice area of california
and somehow in california this place
that was very like seemed very normal
there's just this one place and somehow
this
bowling place was the only place that
gave me mega redneck vibes
and i went in there and it was very much
just like like that but it seemed like
there was just a bunch of people who you
know like i don't know
have you been bowling in japan though uh
no i haven't well then maybe it might
change right now unless there's like
screens and shit's [ __ ] like flat
like
you got to stir like a 10. like a guy
comes over congratulates you unless that
happens no way no way
no i mean it there's how can bowling be
any [ __ ] different in japan to like
other countries
i mean there's no rednecks because
to me it just sounds like the you said
it was the error about it yeah yeah so
but then this whole like
okay other kind of like bowling places
for some reason universally are like the
most like semi-run-down
places out of any of like the
entertainment things i don't know why
bowling's always like places always look
the worst
i mean they're always the cheapest you
know what i mean does anyone understand
what i mean but like but the difference
is that like a lot of bowling alleys in
japan
are run by like round ones yeah so
they'll usually have like the first like
usually with like a lot of big round
ones which is like a huge arcade uh
chain
if you don't know but it's like you know
the first like three floors are like the
arcades and the rhythm games
and then the next like four floors are
all the balls i mean to me it's just
like an activity to do when you're
drinking
i enjoy it but i it's i do think it's
the worst activity out of the bunch
why why plenty of time to talk to your
mates you just throw ball every
few minutes and you get to laugh at your
mate being [ __ ] because either like
everyone's
too invested in the bowling and then
we're not talking right
or nobody's invested in the bowling and
what the most
that's not the kind of people what do
you mean tell me the perfect level of
bowling ratio to conversation ratio i
should be expecting
because what happens is and and this
happens every single time you got
bowling right
everyone's talking oh it's my turn but i
was in the middle of a fun conversation
i don't really want a ball so you just
[ __ ] throw her like a meh bowl
yeah because you're already 10 points
down you're not gonna win this one
you're not gonna get a strike let's be
realistic because you're kind of [ __ ]
bowling right
and you know then someone or sometimes
you okay so then
sorry i'm losing if i'm getting tilted
over bowling
so then you go up you miss out on the
conversation and it just feels like
you're like speed dating
but the one person is not getting a date
who keeps going out
right the rest but i get that if it's if
you're only going bowling with
your date right if there's only two
people it's just mate this is mates
you're in a group and then you leave the
conversation and then no one's really
giving a [ __ ] about the bowling because
having a conversation yeah
it's an excellent it's just like it's
just like a background activity yeah
then what's the point don't do something
else well that's that's exactly the same
as like dumb yeah that's all i have to
say is exactly myself like darts or pool
nah darts you can keep talking while
you're playing darkness you can keep
talking while you're bombing
like what you're gonna do follow him up
to the ball
what are you gonna do follow him up to
the thing like okay okay keep going oh
nice nice ball let's go back now let's
go talk okay yeah i do that sometimes
[ __ ] off i would be like [ __ ] off joey
i'm trying to bowl here don't do it
okay that doesn't make sense because
you're like i don't give a [ __ ] about
the bowling i only care about the
conversation right
i'm bowling right and then when i'm
talking when it's someone else's turn i
give a [ __ ] about talking
you're the most difficult [ __ ] bowler
i just feel like it's a dichotomy and it
shouldn't exist
there's like so many activities i can
think of that you know no they're easier
paul
while you're doing the pool you can talk
while you're doing darts you can talk
everything else you can do
with that it's because it's like a group
activity because we're pulling darts i
feel like it's just like
two people that's doing it yeah but you
can do it with like group like
pool you can all sit around the table
and yeah enjoy it but there's only two
people playing pool right yeah but okay
with bowling you know like tag
because it's such a distance one too
much walking
bowling can i just put that out there
too much water
you have to walk far enough away where
you can't be in the car okay this is
going to sound so [ __ ] dumb all of
this sounds dumb i realize but you have
to walk far enough away where you are
then
leaving the conversation right here but
you don't have to leave the conference
you are you're laughing you're concerned
if the conversation is like how you're
not going to be [ __ ] far away for
like
five minutes you're up there for like
three seconds that's enough to leave the
conference i'll be honest i've never
thought this deeply about that
i thought this is definitely about
everything in my life except for music
and story
so in your mind are you are you thinking
like this could be optimized
this situation could be optimized this
isn't this isn't speed running fun
you know this this is this is fun with
extra steps
there's too much gap between no one
needs that much run up when they're
bowling and if you do
something's wrong with you let's shorten
the distance between where the seats are
yeah
and where the alley starts well then but
i mean you're not gonna have a [ __ ]
500 meter run up the ball
right i know some people who are like i
need the full length well then i don't
want to go bowling with people like that
that just sounds like a douche
you're taking this bowling [ __ ] way too
seriously i just think that bowling
is uh not very optimized sport
for friendship engagement i'm gonna put
it out there
i just think it's not the best i you
know what can i say gentlemen i mean i
don't know i've had like
like because okay because i've been
bowling with like i'm sure like some
people out there that are like conor
knows what he's talking about
he's not monkey brain yeah well they're
the kind of people i don't want to go
bowling with
because i don't know there's always
going to be those comments because
they're going to be like
oh i'm not alone i need to speak up
finally
also bowling feels like an activity
where i shouldn't have to change my
shoes you know what i mean it's it's
that level of
activity that isn't serious enough to
warrant me changing clothes
the shoes part is kind of [ __ ] like
it's not like you're going rock climbing
or something
right like where it's like i understand
i need to bring like you know flexible
clothing right yeah it feels like an
activity that shouldn't require me
changing clothes
and i hate the fact that you always get
the most disgusting rancid shoes
that feel so yeah okay sure they [ __ ]
spray it they give it a little alcohol
like that does [ __ ] anything this
[ __ ] is disgusting okay to be fair
though japan is really good
right with their cleanliness and stuff
like that i've i've never gotten i've
had that
in australia i don't want to [ __ ]
wear my [ __ ] where's waldo shoes
while i'm talking to my friends
eating the most pathetic fries in
existence that have been half cooked
while we have a half good conversation
and overpriced alcohol
i just think bowling needs to be done
better and it's depressing as [ __ ]
i don't know why it looks like someone
said childhood or trouble bowling alley
who hurt you i just show him show me on
the door where okay show me on the
doorway show me
show me on the ball no no no no no no no
no no because my closing statement on
board
okay there's a question i need to ask
you okay because have you had
bad bowling experiences when you were a
kid or is it something that you
know yeah as i become an adult this
became a thing okay because but
now that i have that thought now where i
was like you know what i just realized
because bowling places always had
arcades right
yeah i had more fun in the arcade
whenever i went bowling
so what does that say about bowling
right because you know when you when
there was like
if you'd have a party with like 12 kids
yo you're waiting a long time
i feel i feel like you don't enjoy
bowling for the same reason you skip
stories it's because there's yes like
like
if you could just bowl 10 10 10 balls in
a row and just like
and then conversation yeah yeah i'm sure
you would enjoy it there yeah
but you're just like scared i think i
thought i skipped the other part
i think because it's like i don't know
if you're like this but
when it's like not my turn i have like a
tiny bit of anxiety of like
[ __ ] when's it gonna be my turn i don't
know it's gonna be my turn what am i
gonna get called out i don't want to be
that hard
serious no i know it isn't but this is
the thing someone's not really throwing
balls
somewhere someone out there viewing like
experiences where you're just like yeah
it's kind of anxious just not knowing
when we have to [ __ ] stand up and
throw something
like i just like to know that okay i'm
gonna just do it and then i can come
back you're treating it like it's a
[ __ ] quick time event like
you can go up whenever you want i just
want to talk to my homies or play the
arcades can we separate them
well then maybe well then maybe you'll
enjoy bowling if that's a one-player
game
by yourself i'd be like finally i get
all of them do you know my best
experience bowling was wii sports that
was the best
you know why no waiting i could just
just
just
just
just
just
just
just
just just
just
just
just
just
just
just
just just
just
just
just
just
just
just
just just
just
just
just
just
just
just
just just
just
just
just
just
just
just
just just
just
just
just
just
just
just
just just
just
just
just
just
just
just
just just
just
just
just
just
just
just
just just
just
just
just
just
just
just
just just
just
just
just
just
just
just
just just
just
just
just
just
just
just
just just
just
just
just
just
just
just
just just
just
just
just
just
just
just
just just
just
just
just
just
just
just
just just
just
just
just
just
just
just
just just
just
just
just
just
just
just
just just
just
just
just
just
just
just
just just just just just just just throw that
down and it's 100
optimized yeah yeah and you had that 100
pin bolt that [ __ ] was fun as [ __ ] i
love watching youtube videos people
getting like a thousand pins yeah it's
just amazing it feels good
well then maybe we should do that just
wee bowling yeah he's away
no no i still gotta wait for you to do
your turn i don't like that yeah
you can skip it if you want skip joey's
turn skip skip skip
yeah i feel like talking to you for
enough times i'm like yeah i kind of get
wonky brain now
yeah it's it's starting to make sense
i'm like scientifically dissecting
how your brain is i just think because
you know like certainly pool or darts
you're constantly
like talking next to each other it
doesn't really [ __ ] matter when it's
my turn but bowling because it's like
all right i have to walk up and
you know why don't you walk up with them
and also you know okay i'm not gonna lie
i'm not not a big fan of having to pick
the ball i i don't
know i'm kind of sick of doing that like
because
you've been there right that one place
where you they don't have your [ __ ]
hand size it's like it's either too
[ __ ] big where it feels like
you're trying to you're trying to grab
like three [ __ ] food containers
like large or or it's like yes i want my
fingers to be crushed to death and
potentially just pull my like dislocate
my finger when i throw this
and you know it because you've been to a
place like that no i haven't [ __ ] off
that's why i'm laughing because
you must have been you because i feel
like i'm in a place and you're like i
can't enjoy this bowling
because none of these [ __ ] balls fit
my hand
the one thing i will say about bowling
is that no matter ball you choose
somehow it just doesn't feel right it
never feels good like like like
you you pick a ball you're like this
feels right and then you throw it like
oh that that that didn't feel good
let me go for the smaller one and then
you and you throw it you're like no
that feels too light so go for the
bigger one again and he just i don't
know
you never get the right one you're in a
constant state of like anxiety to be
like
you guys must have gone to some [ __ ] you
know they don't [ __ ] clean those
bowling balls on the inside either
okay that's all the more reason i want
to take you guys to through japanese
bowling ball because
every single thing that you guys have
been complaining about the bowling
experience
i feel is completely get rid of i feel
like i'm in the middle for this like
i don't hate bowling as much as connor
but if i would like to make a
like a tear list bowling's like a good
seat yeah it's definitely the one of the
worst
yeah it's like i'm not going to say that
bowling is like an ester experience or
anything like it's very like a bt for me
as well
[Music]
it's like the fairy tale of
entertainment sports like it's just mid
man
remember i went on a date when i first
got here and then they wanted to go to
baggage so i was like yeah sure
sure and in the back of my head i was
like yeah i'll take it easy on you and
then i just started like [ __ ]
destroying them
and now they're like oh man i guess i
got lucky we started playing darts i
started just [ __ ] crushing them and
that and i'm like yeah good know your
place
i'm joking wow she beat me in darts yeah
i just i just like does the word casual
like mean anything to you like just
playing casually that bowling is a
casual player sport i don't like bowling
it's cause you can't win in it connor
maybe that's why because i [ __ ] suck
at bowling maybe that's why i hate it
yeah actually i always wanted to ask you
like going back to the monkey brain
thing like your opinion on gameplay
and we've had a few comments about this
yeah why don't you like fighting games
that is that's probably for you the game
genre
that would like on in theory yeah appeal
to you the most yes there's no story
it's probably like the one type of video
game that i've just never enjoyed
playing like why is that
i've no i think is like the difficulty
curve is insanely high
and i feel that like i don't want to sit
there and have to research combos
because sure when i pull one off i'm
like cool that animation was
fine i guess you know i i just don't
feel like i care enough about like to
learn these combos
whereas in a game like i don't know like
a first person shooter it's so intuitive
that like it's just one bite right and
like yeah it is very
anyone can figure it out but it's that
one simple mechanic that you keep
mastering and you keep getting better
and better and so it's
kind of like i've noticed that i really
only enjoy games where
it's a easy to learn hard to master type
of thing and fighting game is just
hard to learn even harder i feel
fighting games are easy to learn no
stuff smash maybe yeah smash i think
it's much more yeah i really enjoy smash
is fun because i feel that it's just i
don't know
it's it's not like [ __ ] tekken where
i have to worry about like the frames in
the
spacing and stuff i know i mean like
people in smash worry about that yeah
when you get so high but smash is a
casual game there i said it um
i'm kidding
okay i love watching smash competitive
but for me it's a party game
right oh yeah but that's the great thing
about smash right is that we can be
really
fun to watch as a party game but it's
also a really fun process yeah yeah
because the thing that's really hard
about fighting games is that
it's hardly ever a party game right
because whenever you
are at a party and people are playing
fighting games there's always that guy
or two guys
you know you know who you are you you
see people put on like
smash or tekken and you're like because
they never they never leave that [ __ ]
couch
they will never leave it if they need to
piss they're not going they won't
they'll wait till they get home
fighting games don't wait like this is
what they've trained like their entire
life for
like okay let me let me let me smash the
noobs yeah yeah let me smash all the
people at this party and then they need
to find
other people like them to like continue
on this path that they've put themselves
on
the same people who rock up to an anime
convention just with their like uh
the gamepad and they're like i know
where i'm spending this yes
there's no question about where i'm
spending these three days point me to
the room with the the wii u's
yeah because i feel like with fighting
games it's
yeah it's i i i i
enjoy watching fighting games more than
i i enjoy playing them yeah
you get you get to a point where you're
just smashing buttons you're like i kind
of get it
and then you go online or something and
then you just get destroyed yeah there
is
there is like the difficulty curve as
you said it's just casual
but to be the difference between a
beginner and a casual is like
so [ __ ] massive oh it's huge you know
because you you go from button mashing
to having to learn like basic theory of
fighting games and basic combos and the
difference between that counting frames
yeah yeah and like different stuff the
difference between the beginner and the
casual is so
[ __ ] like okay for example right like
in a game of overwatch right
a pro can be killed by someone who is
absolutely garbage at the game like it's
very plausible that
he could do that right but in a fighting
game the [ __ ] pros
never gonna lose it's not gonna happen
and i think that that element of like
all right well
if i just play better most of the time
i'll always win right which is like it's
because in fighting games there's no
element of chance
yeah anyway like especially if you're at
a pro level because they just know
like what's coming and i think that's
kind of fun and that's the kind of stuff
that really
drives me into like overdrive of wanting
to learn something is that like
i had a chance of beating that guy and i
could have done it if i just keep
practicing i'll easily get it right then
i keep going and that's how i got into
league
so then maybe if you just gave that a go
with like like street fighter or like
mortal kombat
i reckon if you learn one fighting game
you'll be i gotta be honest
yeah i reckon i would be hooked yeah
which is why i don't want to because i'm
already trying to learn like japanese
the last thing i need is
last thing i need is something else
taking over my [ __ ] life fair enough
airfare fighting games people i know who
like fighting games
super chill but their life is fighting
games like they don't talk about
anything else like they're like yeah oh
you had a nice day oh that's cool i had
a nice day learning the smash combos
like it's like it's like what like
they'll bring it up when it's not even
in the conversation
yeah i love leonardo dicaprio but by the
way sorry [ __ ] it
that's what it sounds like sometimes
it's just incredible he's like leonardo
dicaprio somehow turn it into smash and
it's like what
the [ __ ] that's my shame the way i'd
smash my combos it's like what
what strike stop i will say like from
from the outside looking in the fighting
game community looks like one of the
funnest communities to be in
i love the trash talking the trash
talking is so good and it looks so cool
in league of legends they they ban that
[ __ ] i'm like dude i love trash
i love trash talking in video games i
think it's so fun
maybe it's because like the trash
talking in like some of those
communities just go a little bit too far
maybe i mean league of legends is not
true it's like i'm going to kill you and
your family yeah it's like a legit
threat sometimes
but i reserve the right to just type to
someone you're bad like i think that's
come on someone can do it to me i won't
mind it won't ruin my day
i'm not in a sense that's one of the
worst ways to trash talk right if you're
just someone's just typed in
you are bad yeah chad lowercase is like
how dare you it's like the worst type of
insult so i
i i competed on the uh like what one
time i did a gaming tournament with my
universities
yeah i was like really [ __ ] good at
cod um
and so i you're one of those kids yeah i
competed on that so
of course of course you're a call of
duty kid yeah so there was this thing uh
oh my gosh i'll just go on this whole
tangent then now if you guys are fine
with that
i used to when i was like 15 i won a
[ __ ] ton of cod tournaments
uh because uh modern warfare three i
don't know if you've ever played did you
play modern warfare
a little bit i stopped at modern warfare
too okay so modern warfare 3 had this
thing where you could
pay like 40 a year or whatever for like
the
the pass for all the maps and then you
could also go on this website that they
had
and they're like tournaments and i
entered one
and they would have a prize for like
okay first 10 people get uh
shot glasses of call of duty which is
like later as [ __ ] to anyone who's over
there
yeah but fifteen-year-old me was like
i could pull my g fuel into the whoa
i can get something for playing card so
i went to my mates house because i know
that my parents would never let me pull
an all-nighter
bear in mind these tournaments were
essentially what they were was uh
stat tracking so it would be 24 hours
tournament oh wow right of where you
would just it would be like most kills
in team deathmatch yeah
so you would just go into a normal team
deathmatch and just play
and then it would count how many kills
you had in team deathmatch before and
how many had so it's basically just like
who can get the highest score yeah right
so basically it was like you just
[ __ ] keep playing yeah and i shoot
you not i played [ __ ] like capture
the flag
for like 20 hours straight she's doing
this to win these shots like hell to win
these shot glasses
and i was like crippled after it was
like it was worth it
i came like i i'd won so many
at that time that i was able to go to
sleep confidently knowing that no one we
would be able to like overtime yeah all
right i think it came like third or
something i
won and then and then one what happened
was that it all changed
they changed it so that it was three
hours now way more manageable yeah
so i was like sweet i can enter all of
them and they were like most
flags defended and captured weird [ __ ]
yeah yeah so sometimes i would be
sitting at my
base just waiting for someone to take my
flag kill them get it back and then just
go back and count
and i would do this [ __ ] i won like 15
tournaments or something in the end
i won so my room was full of short
glasses tell you what though
what was the best prize you got ipad pro
at the time oh wow
wow ipad when i was like 17 the brand
new ipad at the time
my mom thought that i was like a drug
dealer because she was like what the
[ __ ]
because all this stuff turned up i won
this [ __ ]
huge poker set wooden poker set they
only made 250 of them right and
i still have it at my house because i
couldn't sell it because it was worth
about 700 pounds
jesus it's a wood box like this big
and you open it up and all these like
wooden poker chips handcrafted
card decks dealer chips metal immaculate
i'll show you pictures i'll be on screen
right now it's crazy yeah
um and i was doing these for ages i won
like
three skateboard decks i don't
skateboard what the [ __ ]
uh a hoodie two coaster sets that i
still use actually
metal coasters with like cod skulls on
them right [ __ ] cringe
one like wall decals which i couldn't
[ __ ] use i sold most of the stuff on
ebay
um but yeah i went on an ipad pro which
is the one time yeah and then
i got banned from competing why you
so the rules were not well defined
okay and i was uh i don't know how to
how do i describe
a sneaky [ __ ] you you you bent
the rules too yeah
if i saw an opportunity so when an ipad
pro
i'm going to take the opportunity to win
an ipad pro because it seemed all legit
yeah so
about halfway through these tournaments
i realized okay i'm trying really hard
to win these but i think i can also do
it a lot easier
yeah so basically what i would do is i'd
want a bunch of these tournaments and i
used that like notoriety from those
tournaments
to like recruit people to come okay so
because
it would all it would do is track your
stats right so everyone else on your
team didn't matter
so if you had a team that was
coordinated into making sure that you
were the one getting everything
right so you so you basically smurfed so
what i did was i got like
these like five swedish players yeah and
for some reason the swedish and
norwegian dudes were always [ __ ]
amazing
yeah yeah they were way too good and i
promised them if they helped me win all
these tournaments
i would join their clan
i was like negotiating online i would
shout you out i will join
bear in mind i wasn't worth anything but
to them they were like
he's winning all these tournaments yeah
we gotta get this guy in
so uh did you ever know the game mode
like kill confirmed no no basically a
game
where you killed someone and they would
drop a tank and you'd have to collect it
so there's one tournament that was like
whoever gets the most kill confirms in
three hours one yeah so what i did was i
told these guys i was like hey
kill these dudes and put a marker on the
map of where you dropped it and don't
collect it and
i just ran around collecting them all i
didn't kill anyone and i
it was and i should have not done that
because what ended up happening was like
first place was like 1 200 second place
400. and it raised like a lot of alarm
bells
that doesn't seem fair so
i got away with it for like two or two
or three tournaments before people start
really complaining yeah and people like
this isn't fair he's winning everything
because of this
but then the thing was people started
doing it right so then it was a matter
of everyone was [ __ ] cheating each
other
yeah right and because there were some
real [ __ ] big boy prizes
there was a jeep one of them jesus which
i
[ __ ] i was like 10 points off winning
a [ __ ] jeep at the age of 16.
never mind i was i was winning all these
prizes under my dad's name yeah
because they wouldn't ship it to you if
you uh
they also made me fill out tax forms
yeah which i couldn't even legally fill
out which i
what did you tell your dad that you were
like filling out i was like dad i've won
a bunch of stuff
and it's gonna it's gonna turn up to the
house in a ups fan about 20
items i need you to pretend that you won
them dad
and they were very visibly like what
yeah and then they were like okay
i guess yeah yeah and so the thing that
got me banned right
from these tournaments yeah there was
this one prize
that was you know the movie battleship
with featuring rihanna
yeah yeah yeah horrible they were
promoting the movie battleship yeah one
of the prizes was
you could rent out a whole movie theater
and take all your friends to get drinks
i thought to myself the amount of street
cred i'll get from this is
imagine this is an outstanding move that
no one will experience
okay okay okay okay bear in mind i i
have to say people might have called
[ __ ] on this whole thing but i was
literally
eight hours a day addicted to cod so
straight up like it's like made for me
to do this so
what i had was this was a team death
match tournament i remember this so
vividly
and uh in team death manchester to kill
them yeah so what i would do is i would
ask my friends to go around with riot
shields
and card you ever play it yeah yeah
don't kill anyone okay yeah
if you can trap them in a corner tell me
where they are i'll come over and pop
them in the head right
so what we would do is right i
coordinated it was literally so you
how what what what like incentive did
you give them to like follow
everything [ __ ] nothing i was keeping
holding
i was keeping this all to myself i never
ever told them once i was gonna help
them do it right
i was just like i'm just gonna take the
prizes and you guys can help me they
were like
all right it's good that sounds like a
good deal
i do remember thinking so the swedish
dudes they had a reason right because
i would join their team i did join that
team and we won a lot of tournaments but
yeah
a lot of the other people who helped me
out had no incentive whatsoever i just
wanted to just
have fun yeah it was entertaining as
[ __ ] to just go in
and do this yeah and i i won some of
these tournaments on my own but i was
sweating my ass off like i would have to
like really play my best and so i
thought i'd do that one i can just get
it secured i mean it's in the rules
there's no
rules i was like why am i
sweating when i can just guarantee the w
right like so yeah i did that
and by that time that implemented a
feature where you could see
like a heat map of what was happening
right people were starting to see that
it was like
75 kills to me zero zero zero zero with
my teammates
right and people were like hmm
that doesn't seem like a normal game of
team death
he got a nuke and so
what happened was that they wanted to
make an example out of me and they were
like
no more doing this no one else is
allowed to do this we've banned this
from happening
right yeah and so they banned me from
doing it and i remember
i spoke to the other because there was
like four of us who won all of these
tournaments right right and the other
two were like
30 year old men who worked in like
construction companies and this is like
all they would do in their speed time
and i felt bad for them because i was
like a 15 year old kid being like i'm
gonna take the money that you probably
need i don't need this [ __ ] i'm gonna
take it i love how they banned you
and then you kind of became you like v
for vendetta
it's like i wanted to make a statement
and i got banned for it
but it was worth it to get the doubles
to this day i was like for the the one
year after that i was so [ __ ] bitter
because i was like
it wasn't in their [ __ ] rules they
just did it to make an example out of me
the website shut down five months ago
yeah that website failed five months
after i was like yeah [ __ ] you wow
they emailed me like two years later
being like hey could you fill out those
tax forms we sent you i'm like
and i just never did yeah i'm like what
are you gonna do i live in a different
country what are you gonna do sue me
i was 15 at the time was this website it
was the
official call of duty website it was oh
okay if you wanted to go and track your
stats
you would have to go and do this and you
would okay like ten ten pounds extra
yeah a year
to get access to the tournament man
you're that guy who just tries to cheat
every system in life
oh dude yeah if there's like overall
sheets yeah yeah
yeah it's like if there's like loopholes
or corners to be cut i'll just always
find them because it's like
yeah like that's it works smarter right
yeah like why would i
work harder when i can just do things
easy right like i mean
that's what thought every criminal says
so it was i was not cheating there was
no rule against what i was doing and
they [ __ ]
they banned me because i was too good at
their own game i wasn't cheating i was
just bending the rules
i got mad mileage out of that ipad that
was worth it all that ipad was working
like two thousand dollars yeah yeah so
that was amazing and my mom was like
still like even after was like hmm you
got an ipad yeah you're doing drugs did
you send dick pics to somebody connor is
that how you saying drugs on the side
are you winning son are you waiting oh
that was such a fun time that was like
great that was so fun
i loved doing that because i just won so
much i wish i won the good stuff like
the jeeps yeah
that dude that would have been a mad
flex if you want to just i was just busy
watching anime
yes yeah i remember the jeep i wasn't
close to winning
but there was one time where they had
quad bikes
about like you know like 10 grand maybe
yeah yeah i came [ __ ] fourth and it
was for the top three and i came
fourth by draw oh wow so i'd drawn for
it i didn't get it because of that i was
so annoyed i was like mom
i didn't get the quad bikes
would you even be able to use the quad
bikes i suppose in wales in wales yeah
wait wait wait wait wait wait
people to sell them yeah i think like
four of the 30 people in my class had
quad bikes like it's
everyone had quad bikes for some reason
those were the guys who like came in the
top three yeah
i was like i see you got it that's how
they got it yes i got it
i mean it was yeah i mean i i think it
would have been problematic if i got
that though because i'm not sure how
much my dad could have bullshitted
because i imagine there would have been
a lot more forms involved when it came
to a quarterback
like ups isn't just dropping off a quad
bike insurance and everything right yeah
did he ever find out how you got those
yeah yeah they knew they were just like
the first few tournaments that i said i
won they didn't believe me
yeah until because all of the stuff
turned up at once like these twenty
except one i think around 15 tournaments
total right
and they all turned up at the same day
the prizes and my mum was like in
complete disbelief she was like
you weren't lying what is this
wow i wish i could get my mom onto a
test she probably has a better memory of
it than me because i don't remember it
very well
you you are the epitome of i am winning
dad like i literally was
that hyper-competitive kid when i found
something i really liked it was like
i would get just insanely good at it i
wish i could have that
because i like if i found something that
i was because because in that sense
you're very much like a perfectionist
yeah with that kind of things
i'm not like that i'm just like if i'm
good enough then that's good enough for
me i can never be like that with stuff
but the problem is if i
if i don't have that drive i kind of
don't care about anything
yeah because like it's so fleeting for
me when it comes to gaming
i i in every kind of like competitive
game
i always have this like honeymoon period
where you're just learning the game
and it's just fun yeah and then when you
start playing ranked like ranked for
like the first
few months are like yeah this is this is
pretty fun and then you get to that
you hit the wall you hit the wall and
that's for me when it stops getting fun
yeah that's that for me
is when you it starts becoming like a
nine-to-five grind you know what i mean
this is like i'm not even having fun
grinding anymore this feels like
this feels like another job i'm getting
like angry for some reason over a
[ __ ] video game
i'm like
[Music]
i was one game away from being in master
tier at tft
and i've only been playing it for like a
month and i was like i'm going to be a
[ __ ] pro at tft yeah i'm actually
going to be a pro
yeah and then i i got demoted and i just
lost all interest in the game
i was like to get better the amount of
mind power i'd have to
like exert too much i'm like i can't do
this yeah and you realize like to get
ten percent better would take like eight
hours a day of playing it's like yeah i
can't do it
i can't do it i'd rather be just like an
average joe at like a lot of different
things rather than excel
at like a couple of things i think i
think i'm the opposite i think that's
what i've been i've been like really bad
at a lot of things in my life yeah yeah
but
the things that i do like you're like
[Applause]
when i'm into something i rarely think
about anything else right yeah like it's
like i
only want to do this one thing and i'm
gonna do it as much as possible right
until i'm bored of it and then when i'm
bored of it i pretty much never come
back to it
it's weird every episode just like the
the monk just gets like yeah i know
people are gonna i know because
people i already see some cars who like
connor must be bullshitting one or two
of the stories i i've like
messed up the details and had to like
[ __ ] elaborate like a bit extra
yeah yeah yeah i i guarantee that the
stories where i'm talking about chess
and uh
i get like i see so many people on the
subreddit are being like connor's kind
of
experiencing too much yeah he's [ __ ]
no one human can experience this much
life
right no no no it's it's normally the
the the stupidest stories where i
uh you know maybe uh enjoy the details a
bit more to make it more entertaining
yeah of course with the stories i'm
talking about like that kind of stuff
yeah that was that legit happened
yeah yeah yeah i mean no because like i
don't remember a lot of my life back at
the time
uh back like i think there's just i
don't know if it's like obviously not
you but with jujo do you have like a
blank period in your life where you just
like don't remember much of it yeah
but that's just because i was doing
drugs i'm sorry
there you go if i'm if i'm to be frank
with you that's exactly why
all right like are you keeping that in
mind i'm okay with that
because it's the truth i don't remember
anything okay because there was the time
when we were talking about how you were
getting into anime yeah and then
i think you you mentioned that there's a
reason
i can't really say why that i just
stopped watching anime yeah like
was it was he jacking up obviously is
that what he was like was he like
was it like selling his body for sex
like what was it it's like no i was
doing drugs
that's i'm just gonna put it out there
not hard drugs no
i just like to pinpoint that not hard
drugs but yeah
that's but that's the thing right like
that's where i had that blank of just
like i wasn't really
doing anything with my life and all i
was really doing was like playing music
or like playing games but not to the
extent that you were playing games i was
just like [ __ ]
on new grounds playing the bullshittest
like dumbest [ __ ] flash games that
have ever existed
yeah i guess for me like the only thing
i've i've been super invested in
is like my career now which is like
youtube and yeah i do think of youtube
as a game yeah
it's totally a game it's totally
gamified yeah yeah that's pretty why
i've been able to like you know i guess
i guess because like i don't know
like the way i see it is kind of like
you have [ __ ] optimized youtube game
though
i don't know how i feel i think that
there are many aspects that it shares
with a game
right unfortunately yeah i mean there's
still a huge creative aspect of it but
i think there's ways to like iterate on
yourself that are very game-like
yeah it's like you do i feel like social
media in general is a game yeah
like you look at something like twitter
where i think i remember i watched this
uh
series by this guy called charlie
brooker who made he made a series called
like the top
most influential video games of all time
all right and he put number one
was twitter and like when and at first i
was like what what the [ __ ] you talking
about twitter is in the game and then
you think about it where like
oh yeah you uh play an avatar online to
uh farm
numbers and the more like the more you
get into it the more numbers you farm
yeah and i'm just like
you know he's he's kind of got a point
yeah because like he's right yeah
nobody really you're like playing a
version of yourself
but it's not like you don't show all of
yourself online no one ever does show
themselves online yeah you gotta
optimize every tweet you make right yeah
like
should i do i phrase it in this way like
is this funny thing to tweet
i don't know how some people can [ __ ]
tweet like 50 tweets in a day
i don't think i have 50 tweets like 50
thoughts in the day let alone like 50
right
when you're do you ever get those
moments you're like i want to find that
one funny tweet from that account and
then you're scrolling and scrolling and
scoring you're like oh it's only been
seven hours ago
what the [ __ ] stop tweeting you tweet
too much it's like how many
that's the thing it's like it's are you
just like are you just not that kind of
person where you just can't like think
about the thought to yourself it's like
i have to
make it i have to put this out into the
world some people get like a [ __ ]
coffee at starbucks like
i got a coffee from starbucks oh my god
hashtag relatable
my god man yeah twitter is a game and
it's a hard game but i enjoy it
damn that's that's gonna be a [ __ ] i i
wanted to go in episode two where i
didn't tell a [ __ ] elaborate stupid
long story but i completely remembered
that i used to [ __ ] play card
competitively
i couldn't even get to the reason why i
brought it up but that's a story for
another time right there that's all
right we'll we'll leave it for the next
evening
remember how this episode was about
japanese nightlife hey man we spoke
about that long enough
cod came up i think that was like i said
everything i wanted to say about
japanese nightlife we'll come back to it
when we've experienced more of it
yeah i feel like there's so much more of
japanese in that life we need ways to
the trash taste special in a soap land
we're gonna go
if you don't know what a soap blend is
it's uh it's a place where you get clean
yeah with soap you have a service
you cleanse you cleanse yourself so you
have a service and they don't advertise
which soap they use they advertise which
women are doing it
and you can figure out why that's the
case on your own yeah i would i was
concerned with well what kind of you
know
scrubbing method yeah i was like i need
to know the phrase
do i do i bring my own loofah or are
they going to
have one though they need to bring a
shower cap yeah did they use their own
soap or should i bring my
like i have a handkerchief
yeah meanwhile the guy's getting a hand
job next to me and i'm like whoa that's
kind of cool yeah
i'm not okay with the soap i've never
been to one by the way trying to make
that very clear before someone [ __ ]
assumes so
and i'm sure you guys haven't as well
yeah
[Laughter]
yeah but uh that's about it for this
episode that's a pretty
good way to wrap it up but hey check out
these amazing people on patreon who
support us look at all these lovely
people pro gamers are good at cod and
hate bowling
[ __ ] bowling hashtag [ __ ] balls yes no
don't hashtag fuckbowling
bowling is depressing no it's not a
bowling is okay please
please comment your thoughts on bowling
down below you know what's not
depressing though our twitter and
subreddit
yes some great [ __ ] memes over there
so follow us over on there as well and
if you'd like to support the show
then make sure to go over to our patreon
as well yeah and i i think you've said
everything i have nothing else to add to
that
i looked over at you like anything else
like i saw you in like the corner of my
eye and i'm just like i don't know what
you expect me to say
you're literally looking at me you
actually shouted everything out i'm just
like i said everything i had to say
hello please help please and this in
this
misery right now you could have just
said like oh thank you very much goodbye
yeah and i'm like what what what do you
want me to say joey
sometimes i feel like i'm not the monkey
what do you mean
if that's been fresh taste i'm not
answering that question joey
[Music]
you